five four
three two one the first man to smoke
marijuana never really smoked and he
inhaled it
he was a chinese man he was a very great
man and whenever he lit the the
the plant it wasn't to get high but he
would start to get high
and every time he got high a blue bird
would come to him
and tell him to conquer his neighboring
neighborhoods
and he listened to those to the bird and
that's exactly what he did and he became
a great emperor
in china and at that point in the story
pablo escobar looks at his doctor and he
goes have you ever been to disneyland
and the doctor goes no pablo i haven't
he gross
very clean very organized
whoa that's it but it's the truth the
first guy that ever got high was the
chinese dude that burnt the plant
because he liked the smell of the plant
it gave him a soothing but after days of
doing it
it packed up in his body and he started
hallucinating he saw a bluebird
a blue bird came to him and told him
that he had to conquer the neighborhoods
within the region what a crazy bird
he got high and a bird started talking
to him what are you gonna do you know
i don't know if this is true but this is
one of the things that uh
the pot aficionados always used to say
is that you know when a
priest walks down the aisle and they
have that that thing that they swing
and there's burning incense inside of it
that used to be weed
that's what they used to do in what
dimension
i don't know at one point i believe it
was weak
then it became that [ __ ] that batman
shot at the green hornet it was like
pedophile smoke you
you wake up your shirts bomb backwards
and [ __ ] your pants are missing
[Laughter]
well what did what is it now what kind
of incense is it now it's like this blue
smoke
i i go in there to church every once in
a while you have to go for the full
effect one like the five in the
afternoon on saturday
and the early morning and sunday they
don't break out the incense
they don't start breaking out the
[ __ ] maluki [ __ ] uh
and the guy comes out and one guy comes
out their own water jesus
and then the other guy it's so weird how
somebody made a great point on twitter
the other day they said
you me mitch hedberg there's five of us
that delivered newspapers
there's five comedians the delivered
newspapers you
hedberg did it yeah you delivered them
in a car to other places
i was an [ __ ] that took a route but
not the route in my neighborhood
to routing the neighborhood over so i
had to beat the kids there before they'd
get there and steal the papers
i would deliver them right to the doors
and oh you did too yeah yeah
and then you collected yeah i collected
from only a handful of people
most people were on like a monthly
subscription plan they they were
switching over
but the people that you'd have to
collect from you had like this envelope
like a tan envelope and you had to like
mark off
like you know when they owed things i
barely remember it because it was only a
couple of clients
and after a while i kind of got away
from doing them i said i don't want to
do these people that have because it's
too hard to collect it's annoying like i
don't want to i don't want to have to go
that was my specialty i didn't like it i
must have been that was
when i first got to the catholic school
and my mom gave me an option that i had
to go up there and work in the
afternoons and i'm like i got to figure
something out
i just don't want to go up there anymore
and my friend said i'm giving up my
newspaper up but he didn't give up the
one in my neighborhood
he gave up the one in the next city over
the next town over in that city
i could still walk everything so i'd
have to leave school and run over there
because i'm not the dude would steal my
papers
and sell them as their own on the
[ __ ] street corners
so i'd have to get them put the
circulars in put them in the thing and
then throw them on people's balcony and
then on fridays and saturdays
i have to go back with a ring after
dinner
and collect how you doing mr rogan i'm
here to pick up 75 cents and they give
you like 1.50 that was your tip
right and you got like 22 cents a week
for delivering the paper
did you collect from everybody i
collected from everybody i was there
sufficient what years were these
this has to be 73
74 75 yeah so i guess when i started
doing it is when i started driving
which had been like 83
i probably started 83 i probably started
when i was 17.
no that was 85 85 probably then that's
when i probably started doing it yeah
you're too old to be collected i
wouldn't pay you either
well it wasn't even that it was just
annoying like what you wanted to do
was go to the depot pick up the papers
chuck them into the people's driveways
and that's it and then there's a few
people that wanted it inside the door
so you'd have to get out of your car
open up their screen door put it in
there
and then leave and the idea was that
those people everybody would say those
people would tip you better those two
they'll tell you about it like okay and
so we would
only have like a few of those and
i think after the first couple of years
they stopped doing those kind of
collections or
i definitely stopped doing them but it
was an awesome job
when you're like a young comic or you
know even before i was
a comic when i was fighting it was just
uh i didn't have to do anything
where someone was telling me what to do
i could get in my car
i could listen to whatever i wanted to i
listened to charles lockwidera
he had the the morning the big mattress
on uh i think it was bcn i'm pretty sure
wbcn in boston this is awesome radio
show
i'd listen to that chuck newspapers out
windows i do that for like three hours
every day
you know it was the best job ever
because then i would make enough money
or i could pay my bills
but i still had all the time in the
world you stand up
all the time in the world train all the
time in the world do anything
but it definitely [ __ ] me up because
you're not supposed to be getting up
that early every day
like that can't be good for you you know
if you
you listen to people that know things
about sleep
like getting up at 4 30 in the morning
or five in the morning every day
and not being responsible that was the
beginning
to me that was the beginning of the new
joe rogan emerald podcast
that was the first podcast i listened to
that i agreed with a lot
but i also had a couple mitigating
factors
because i believe that everybody's
body's a lot different i know i could
rock and roll i could throw down on
seven straight
but it's got to be seven straight no no
no get up the p
two times because once you're 50 it
could be up and down
see once you turn 50 48 everything
changes papa
so if you see you're there at night i'm
drinking completely with water
that has to come out throughout the
night and you will be up all [ __ ]
night on the hour every hour there's no
rem sleep
yeah there's no rem sleep so you have to
come
once you get old you have to come uh
control your thyroid dog i've been a
specialist on sleep
since day one that was one of the most
interesting podcasts
you had on i bought the book and
everything and he made some great points
in there
i didn't i wasn't raised on an app joe
roger
my mom didn't raise me under that once
we came from cuba
my dad died there was no nap i went
where she went
right so my day consisted of eight to
three in the morning she had a manager's
room in the back of the bar with a cot
and if i got tired at one go back there
and take a nap but
i gotta stay here till three mommy got
to work wow
so my sleep was always horrific
then when i was like five or six
in school then i went to normal sleep i
went to catholic grammar school normal
sleep
everything was normal but my mom had a
bad thing that she did
my mom had an issue that a lot of
parents don't do when they work nights
it was she did it from the heart because
i have a friend who does it
wake me up at three in the morning joe
rogan joe rogan
get up i brought you black ink and pasta
which one julie from umbertos
and i brought you a newspaper are you
[ __ ] kidding me can you imagine if i
woke you up every night or two when
you're 26 years old joe
at 3 30 in the morning and you know i'm
doing it from my heart
and seven out of 10 times you're going
to get up and eat the scruggily or the
or the marinara sandwich i brought you
from leo's because they worked in the
city
so i remember if you bartend in new york
city on the way home what are you gonna
do you're gonna stop no you stop and get
two slices of [ __ ] the best pizza
there is in manhattan so my mom would
wake me up every night at 3 30 in the
morning
with a cuban sandwich
that killed me over the years that would
make me get up every night at 3.
there's still nights that i'll be
sleeping i'll get a good night's sleep
but i'll look at the clock and it's 3
a.m on the [ __ ] dot
because it's in my but like last night i
slept good
i [ __ ] up my sleep was bad after i
read the book for a while
that's how deep it got into my head so
when i went back to weight watchers i
realized i couldn't eat any more [ __ ]
edibles
because they wouldn't they would make me
hungry at night
i would [ __ ] go off the charts with
points so i stopped eating edibles and
joe rogan my sleep pattern changed
bad like my body did not
know how to go to fall asleep by itself
i went through a month of
[ __ ] two hours of sleep jesus
doing a bunch of [ __ ] and then three
more hours in the app did you try
anything did you try like melatonin or
anything like that
i did cocaine for 30 years melatonin
that i could eat 20 turkeys they could
all suck my dick
i drink them all together the tea the
vine
leave me alone please leave me the [ __ ]
alone all right
go [ __ ] yourself i got something that's
gabba gabba
the tea and the tryptopian put together
and they still don't find i buy it on
amazon
not bad so what i learned to do was
rotate it
so now i'm back on the animals i found
about an expired bag of cheaper shoes
like from the dave chapel tour when i
went out with dave jesus
i found the bag with about 24 oh my god
i slice them in half you take one of
those
you wake up at six in the morning to pee
your pee's brown
they're expired you understand me
[Laughter]
what happens if you eat expired edibles
same thing when you're eating expired
vicodin
listen to this listen to this listen to
this this [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] around
though
this works the jaw this is you're going
to fight joe schilling eat two of these
and call me back on monday it works
nobody ain't nobody knocking you out
after eat one of these
things those things put you in another
dimension oh my god i've been in a
[ __ ] another dimension since last
week and i don't give a [ __ ]
i have not left the house in a week do
you understand me i ate two of them on
saturday i know you were up in idaho how
beautiful was idaho
beautiful how were the audiences they
were amazing tremendous tremendous it's
like
the nicest people it's like a bunch of
really smart people that said you know
what
[ __ ] california [ __ ] portland
[ __ ] new york [ __ ] chicago they're gonna
get mad we're blowing up boys they want
to keep it low-key oh yeah no no they
want to keep the low-key as [ __ ]
all those areas you could ski up there
they got everything up there nobody
knows yeah they got a couple people that
hate black people
but they keep him on the side of the
state mark furman's up there [ __ ] o.j
sister-in-law
you know what i'm saying it's all right
it's all right
no no no it's beautiful and then you
were in tucson my friend know i
kidnapped showed up to your show
he said he had a great time i go why
don't you say hello to rogan you could
have done the podcast right there
he said he was embarrassed
damn but saturday night i
ate the [ __ ] edible joe rogan i ate
two of these expired ones
i ate one then i said let me take a
chance saturday night i ate another one
and i noticed your movie was coming out
and it is
[ __ ] what a phenomenal movie midnight
express
when they catch the kid coming back from
turkey with hash on his body
john rogan that is one of the most
hardest movies
you'll ever [ __ ] watch in your
goddamn
the first 30 minutes of that like i
thought i was gonna die
like when they let him go through and
they played him and as soon as he hit
the [ __ ] plane
they turned him around ripped his shirt
and they dropped to their hands and
knees and they gave him the seven years
and they started raping them
jesus but i watched up to the part where
[ __ ] uh
he became friends with this dude they
had a cat and the dude name was likey
likey lecky was the guy's name and lucky
killed the cat
and they let this american know you know
that point where
even michael douglas and what was that
movie
he's on a 405 and he just snaps fighting
back michael douglas and [ __ ] then they
try to rob him the three mexicans tried
to rob him from a suitcase
what was this what was that movie called
falling down falling down
he had like his day like that was it
that was
the last day to [ __ ] live
this [ __ ] dude finds out they killed
that poor american's cat and he throws a
[ __ ] beat
on this left he did it joe rogan is one
of the most disturbing beatings there's
two disturbing beatings in film history
that's number two because he closes it
out because the guy was a rat
so after he throws a beating on look
yeah yeah yeah right there
he's spitting out the guy's tongue in
the air
and they showed it i gotta give a shout
out to turner classic movies
you [ __ ] been throwing heat the
last six nights they had on something
else last night they had the gambler on
the other night
that followed this this is the 40th
anniversary joe rogan
he throws a beating on him opens his
mouth
i'm thinking the guy's being a nice guy
he's gonna give him out the mouth and
save the guy's life
[ __ ] no you see him going
unless he just pulls up like this joe
they slow it up
only i'll call a [ __ ] real director
they had on the waterfront last night
jesus
yeah they ain't [ __ ] around and they
curse
once i was watching like what is the
commercials and they said [ __ ] one time
i might as well play this hand out
they're going to show the tongue
joe rogan he takes it out you could see
the rage from the [ __ ] eight years in
that turkish jail getting [ __ ] in the
ass
eating that hummus drinking that [ __ ]
watered-down teeth from lexi and he just
spits his [ __ ] tongue in the air look
at his beating the best beating of all
time
there's only one better beating our boy
the mexican when he beat up
the pilot there this is lepke jesus
dude i forgot about this movie this is a
classic
this is a classic 70s movie
this is crazy dude look at him he's just
this is eight years of getting beat up
every day
i'm not i'm gonna [ __ ] kill you you
[ __ ]
[ __ ] dude
this is an intense scene what year is
this movie 78
i was a kid i still remember going to
see this in the movies and leaving that
like
dog i ain't ever going to turkey jesus
christ
the scene for the people that are just
listening um
he's he's tearing apart this bathroom to
get
this guy i don't remember who the guy is
he's the guy that sells
watered down hash and he rats you out
and he's just a creepy [ __ ] dude and
then to finally push him over the tap
he hangs his cat he wakes up to his cat
being hung
and right here people this is the
[ __ ] strength of the 70s
balls to the wall oh smashes them
yeah no this is real d over here right
here look at that look at him
look at him
oh [ __ ] are you [ __ ] nuts good
morning it's the fourth of july
you're [ __ ] with an american
[ __ ] even in turkey we lose our
[ __ ] minds
that guy must have been half armenian or
something when he bit his tongue out of
here there you go
dude this was this guy ended up dying of
age in real life
this is a strong strong next time you
have
flowers the real life guy enjoys this
guy the actor
who was he what was this i forget what
his name brett brett
brad davis jesus then the second best
beating
is our man anthony quinn
at the end when he when he was 80
he beat the [ __ ] out of the good looking
dude for [ __ ] his
girlfriend mario stowe madeleine stowe
in a movie called revenge that is
oh yeah i remember revenge kevin costner
kevin costner
and then he slices her face and he
[ __ ] puts her in a whorehouse right
to get [ __ ] in the ass every the hour
[ __ ] this is it it's the fourth of
july dawg get your [ __ ] together you
know what i'm saying
if alexis jones is correct we're going
to have a civil war today so what the
[ __ ]
you talked to alex you got to calm them
down alex you got to calm down
talking about a civil war he had me
doing an extra achievement show the
other night
i was polishing the [ __ ] uh the
musket
alex thinks i'm defending the new world
order because i didn't think that george
soros was a nazi
oh it's it's all so painful
what's up joe nothing what's happening
brother everything's great man me too i
feel good
alex jones i love you buddy for real
but you say some silly [ __ ] that's where
this all comes from
doesn't mean i don't love you you're a
great guy
but there's some [ __ ] that's just silly
it's wasted time
you know that's one of those things
that's just a waste of time
does that make sense i'm with you i
think there's real conspiracies
you know but i think there's some that
you know people just get caught up and
looking for conspiracies and everything
and after a while it's exhausting
let's get the bull off the table i love
the guy i love the podcast with ari last
week
yesterday tina turned his son
alex jones going to hear this so i'm
just i got finished okay i'm so sorry no
it's okay it's just
i love the guy i really do i just don't
support
a lot of the [ __ ] that he said like the
sandy hook stuff
i don't know if he's since disavowed
that i don't know if he changed his
opinion on it i don't know what it is
but
at a certain point in time you're like
jesus man are you
are you sure like you got to be really
sure before you say something crazy like
that
right
don't you i mean don't you think look i
think he's a great guy
and as a person i'm not attacking him
i just uh when he goes crazy he gets mad
at me
i love i want to hug him i love when he
told me this story about
trucks pulling up in front of your house
and they could see through your walls
they probably can do that they do that
in different neighborhoods
you know they probably can do something
like that but then after five of those
and this is my experience with him he'll
tell you something that you got to sit
there and go what the [ __ ] am i doing
sitting here
but that's cool that's alex and we
accept him for what the [ __ ] he is
i just thought there was a civil war
starting today i read on
that's what he was saying the democrats
are going at it today so somebody's
shooting somebody so who the [ __ ] knows
so just to calm alex down nobody's
telling me what to say
no one's telling me what to do i'm not
involved in a new world order who's the
new world
just because enlighten me about the new
world i'm not sure
i'm not involved though i just want alex
to know i'm not involved who are those
people you eating dinner with the other
night will you get a new world daughter
who's the dinner people the people you
say you were eating with smartphones oh
they're just these are all podcasters
and
former professors and all these
different people that are doing
uh different things together you scared
me the other day though you had any
right he was thinking he went back with
the cia what
what yeah you know you got back on the
ropes show what are you talking about
you know he's not going to say i ain't
who knows what
nothing okay what the [ __ ] are you
saying
he's a cheap of you it's the fourth of
july
no fireworks like [ __ ] cbs radford i
think
i think conspiracies are fun and that's
part of the problem with conspiracies
they're fun
they're fun to chase down they really
are they're interesting i'll tell you
what's fun to chase down
to read about one and to absorb it by
yourself
once i get into a room with three men
and we're on a conspiracy for 48 minutes
that's when i get aggravated well that's
what i don't ever want to talk about
that's what the [ __ ] that kills me i
don't have the time to discuss with a
little moon landing or not
we all have an idea what we think
happened guess what
i really don't want to talk about it not
on the [ __ ] fourth of july yeah
no the the problem with them is and this
is a tendency
is that when people get really into
conspiracy theories they're into
everything being a conspiracy that's not
like they're into conspiracy theories
and also into the history of cuba
then give you a detailed history of some
really crazy [ __ ] that went down
like how many people that are really
into conspiracy theories could give you
a rundown on how castro
took over cuba which is like a real
thing that happened
in you know our parents lifetimes
right think about that
how many people that are into like you
know whether or not there's
bases on the moon know about
you know all these different things that
have happened through human history the
mongols
the roman empire the greek empire there
was crazy [ __ ] that definitely really
happened
all the stuff that happened during the
vietnam war all the stuff that happened
during the nixon administration all that
stuff's real
it's fascinating fascinating [ __ ] to
look into
but then you get to dumb ones like oh
god are we really discussing whether or
not the earth is flat
is this a real conversation like people
really doing that
satellites aren't real go on social
media
you'll find a bunch of people to that'll
agree with you too
you've got to be so careful about not
listening to scientists
i saw on saturday on sunday night sunday
night on the 50 years of 60 minutes
they were showing how they interviewed
different people and how
the one guy went to assam hussein
saddam hussein and he said to him and
ask him to tell him that this guy said
he's crazy
and the interpreter looked at him and
says you did you think sorry i
ain't asking that and there was but
there was one particular interview
and he was just talking about the
interview he was one of the best
interviews he ever did
was when he pushed the guy the guy that
was standing behind kennedy in the car
the the the agent
that should have taken the bullet for
kennedy
they interviewed that guy that's a great
you gotta hunt that one down
that he was one step behind i mean he
breaks down into tears he's a real
american like this is a guy that's
a real american took that job and then
like it wasn't your fault
and he's like you don't understand i was
a second
behind if i would have been there just
one second early i would have caught it
in my back and
the president would have been a lot i
mean it's [ __ ] crazy
jesus can you imagine being dedicated to
protect a guy with your own life
and to really drink the serum
and to believe it like like a [ __ ]
soldier
those are very special human beings that
can do that
it's not a lot of human beings that have
that kind of resolve
will throw their life in front of a
bullet to protect someone else's that's
intense
that is intense and you have to hear
where the bullet is coming from what
your response time has to be
to be this is when you're a real
high level bodyguard
this is you are the highest of the
highest your hearing
is impeccable this means when you're
walking down the street
with this guy inside you have to learn
by yourself how to shut off nature
and noises and listen to footsteps
weapons clicking holsters opening
think of how interesting just that alone
is
that's why sometimes when you see them
they're holding one ear
because they're zeroing in on anything
particular a
car's tires screeching differently
think of that [ __ ] job because that's
what their job is
to react to that so if this if joe rogan
has eight guys
when they train and i don't even know i
i've never trained them quantico
but i just know that i guarantee the
first two guys the first four guys are
lead guys
they have a mission one guy gets to the
door if there's a shooting
the other guy duck two guys duck for the
president
there's gotta be plans like it's like
formations in football
what if the linebacker goes this way you
run around me
this doesn't take a [ __ ] genius to
tell you there has to be formations to
protect the president
or whoever it is you're protecting in
that level
when i'm protecting kevin hart how many
people are going to try to assassinate
kevin hart
when i'm protecting a president
how many people are going to really try
to shoot that president
with weapons i mean let's go to the
ronald reagan attempt let's go to these
attempts
how [ __ ] fast this is you have to be
so high elite
vietnam another war and then you had to
do a tour of something else where you
were just like a spook that you tiptoed
people with toothpicks and [ __ ] like
this this is my
this is what i think you're training you
i don't think you're just born to be
rambo i think they have to take you to
government
and they start with a hundred rambos
they just keep
training training training you lose some
along the way
and after every hundred you get eight
[ __ ] savages
that never had chance to get married the
government never gave him a chance to
get married
they're that good well all these guys
that i know
that have been navy seals all of them
are
any special forces guys just
you those are different humans you know
they're just different people now what's
jaco
navy seal okay yeah and um
there's just a level that you have to be
you have to have more control over your
mind more control over your will
more control over your discipline you're
you're in the most
elite branch of the military i mean this
is the elite of the elite i mean they
make it it's insanely difficult to get
in
so you just get the cream of the crops
the people who are they just their
mental fortitude
is just unlike an average person if you
meet a
bunch of people like that man you
realize like wow people come in
all kinds of different levels there's
people that just only surround
themselves with
other excellence and those dudes like
those jocko type dudes or tim kennedy
type dudes
those that's a like a different kind of
human
like they don't make a lot of those if
you just want to have only those
boy you gotta there's a lot that has to
happen before you can become a person
like that you have to
you have to travel through many valleys
of the mind and the body to get to be a
person like that
a person of uh insane resolve in a time
of war
it's a very very intense human being
it's it's not even a time of war look at
these 12 filipino kids in the [ __ ]
back cave stuff
down there look who went to get them the
[ __ ] seals
the seals the seal team went down that
again is that what happened
well there's different various agencies
but there's also a seal team there
makes sense you know the seal team that
that's as
elite as elite so
do you i don't even know that's how you
probably become a [ __ ]
uh bodyguard to the president you'd have
to [ __ ] start like as an attache
somewhere
for a year or two with a suit on just to
adjust a human life and life without
[ __ ] hearing bombs go off every 20
minutes and [ __ ]
yeah and then move up in that system
until you get to that level of the
secret service
there's no way you're going to be a seek
they put you through a secret service
training school
and you're there in 60 [ __ ] days let
me tell you something
i go and my daughter goes to science
camp
you know whatever the [ __ ] until pre-k
starts
i'm one of the kids she goes with his
dad's an fbi agent
so you know what my job is every day to
sneak up on him
every day i sneak up on him and put a
gun to his side and i know what's going
on and i
pat him in the back and he giggles and
[ __ ] i tell my wife every day he's the
worst fbi agent i've ever seen in my
life
because i'm too late and i'm tiptoeing
up to him you don't even hear me in
bushes or nothing like that that's how
good i
am do you know why dog because they hire
him right i'm an academy today joe rogan
right out of college
that's why we have so many shootings
that's why we have so many accidents
out there with police officers they
don't hire neighborhood kids anymore
they hire college graduates that have
never had
what we had see when you were growing up
if
all else failed you've never been
arrested in your life
you really could have been a cop you're
a nice guy
but you really could have been joe the
cop you could have been joe the
cop and quincy mass that drives around
and [ __ ] like that sure anybody could be
anybody could be a cop
but joe the cop would have been
different if joe the cop would have came
in here and seen me and jamie argue
joe the cop wouldn't arrest me and jamie
joe the cop would say i want to meet you
[ __ ] tomorrow at three
and he would give us both boxing gloves
and we would box it out when we were 12
and both go home and get ice cream the
next day
joe the cop wouldn't throw us both in
jail joe the cop wouldn't throw us
against the wall
and if we turned around he'd shoot one
of us in the [ __ ] leg
he was part of the community joe the cop
and joe on the cop
knew what it was like living in that
community as a child
do you understand me so and i didn't
know this i've been thinking about a lot
about this and i ran into somebody and i
asked him the next cop
why are we having the situations we're
having in this country
the one last week in [ __ ] east
pittsburgh
is just mind-blowing
that [ __ ] just now there's a lot
of different angles for that
they had just finished doing a shootout
but the kid took off this cop watched
him said
okay got down drop down military style
and blast them three times
shoot me in the leg [ __ ] shoot me in
the leg for running away that's what joe
the cop would do
yeah but even shooting someone in the
leg running away but it's got to be
something that they did that's really
[ __ ] up
well listen i believe this should be
shooting on my left leg i'd rather shoot
you in the leg than take your [ __ ]
life
i hear you i'd rather shoot you in the
leg than take your life
if it's an iffy call but just show you
so you know
it's not safe to shoot someone in the
leg people die from getting shot and
elected
i shot you in the [ __ ] ankle no okay
but i'm just touching the wrists
i just i don't want to give anybody the
impression they can just go around
shooting people
how many movies did we grow up but the
guy got shot in the shoulder he just
went
you know what i'm saying you live
getting shot favorite is they get pistol
whipped
and then when they wake up it's like
nothing happened they just start duking
it out
they got pistol whipped everybody was
pissed a whipping people remember that
they would just club them in their head
with the pistol
that was so crazy that was like a thing
and then these people would wake up why
what happened
i didn't get pistol whip with the butt i
got pistol whipped with the
the gun to the head nothing bled thank
god
but it [ __ ] hurt i don't know what
the [ __ ] type of gun it was like an
automatic like uh like a nine millimeter
type thing it wasn't like a revolver
i never got hit with the butt more what
a weird feature
of the human body if that you hit it in
the right spots it goes
out like we have like a plug
we have like a loose like some people's
plugs a little looser than others
some people's plugs like mark hunt it
takes forever to knock it loose
some people could just take it and some
people can it's [ __ ] weird
it's a weird characteristic you hit
people and they go unconscious
it's very strange it's a very strange
feature that we exploit you know
but in movies they always make it like
it's no big deal it's a big [ __ ]
deal it's a big deal you should avoid
having it done to you
it's a big deal to get knocked
unconscious
you know it's so weird when we first
started hanging out one afternoon
you took me to see that boxing coach and
at the time he had four academy award
guys he was training
was that terry claibon travis claymore
terry's
amazing he's a great guy we walked in
there we went upstairs and i think uh
at the time when we walked up nicholas
cage was up there at the time
with his little head piece on and [ __ ]
looking like johnny goombah and stuff
and then
terry came over and gave you a hug and
we went downstairs
and tyree grabbed steve simone later on
because steve worked there at the time
this is 97 98 as a gym oh yeah
and he goes boy that guy's in the wrong
profession as a comic he should have
been a boxer hits like a meal
you know and i never forgot that him
saying that and all the stuff you talk
about
brain damage and whatever
it took a lot for you to at that age to
realize that
this was [ __ ] for real this was this
was dangerous
there was no money in it there was no
temptation this head that this head [ __ ]
is not this is real it was real but
there was also
i didn't have any temptation
what happened before this like what
happened to
the guys that i saw playing black
football and black and white with
leather helmets
well you know leather helmets are safer
believe it or not because you don't feel
as confident
when they had those leather helmets they
didn't crash into each other the same
way
there's not there's a opinion i don't
know if i agree with it because i don't
know much about the sport
but there's an opinion that no pads
no helmets football would be safer
because you wouldn't be able to do the
same things that they're doing now you
can't just run into people head to head
you'll just just destroy you and you can
only do it a few times your body would
just start breaking
but if you you're putting helmets on and
pads it accentuates your ability to run
into someone with all your force that's
unnatural and it creates an unnatural
jarring of the body in the brain
that the rugby guys don't get the rugby
guys don't have all those pads
so when they're clashing into each other
they're learning how to roll with things
they're not just colliding into each
other they're not
there's a different game when you've got
padding so if you take away the padding
people have to be more careful in how
they're
engaged they can't just charge in and
smash into each other they won't last
i don't know i don't know interesting to
find out i remember being a kid dog i
don't i'm from jersey it's a real good
question
[ __ ] jersey right yeah we know
football i didn't even know soccer back
then when i lived in jersey
in osaka's a couple spanish people
played the dark side
of the of the court they played soccer
on sundays they wouldn't even let nobody
watch
a couple spanish guys but besides that
soccer was not big in my area
but uh when i moved to aspen
i would go to aspen on saturday just to
walk around get a beer get a sandwich
and i'd see rugby i had never saw that i
didn't know what the [ __ ] it was
right and i was like in good shape and
after about three times and i went one
of the guys said to me why don't you
show up
on a [ __ ] saturday and i looked at
them like what are you crazy
like i don't even know what the [ __ ] you
guys are doing they have a big rug
rug fest in aspen every year pretty much
every year
that's why i first saw rugby was in
colorado i mean i don't think i've ever
seen it live i've only seen it on tv
yeah no i've seen it live and it's
yeah that's when you see that you know i
saw three
i saw two things that blew me away live
in colorado i saw rugby
and i saw when they did like a tour de
france star type race
but they did it snowmass village and i
knew exactly what it was
the road up and how it would have to be
a circle to go and you didn't have to go
back down to
route 82 right you would just do circles
around snowmass
and i still remember being on a hill
listening to them going up the hill
and it just blew my [ __ ] mind the way
the tire was hitting
the speeds like the how fast they were
going
uphill and then 20 years later you
realize they're doing ppos and [ __ ]
hanging out with sheryl crow's old
husband shooting all that [ __ ] can you
imagine when they were shooting in the
80s when i saw them
jesus was [ __ ] stronger back then
i can only imagine what's the drug that
they shoot that their legs won't stop
moving at night so they gotta get on the
bicycle
oh epo it's not the delay
apparently i'm probably saying it wrong
but uh they have this feeling
like they have to exercise one of our
buddies was a uh
a biker and you know his professional
tour guide just like
you know not like a super famous super
successful one but he was a you know
professional bike rider
what would you call one of those cyclist
a professional cyclist
and he would tell us about it how guys
you'd hear them he knew that they were
on epo and then you would hear them
uh when they were on a tour bus they'd
get up in the middle of the night and go
ride their bike
like they felt like they had to exercise
so
i guess if you're on a lot of it i don't
know
i've never done it it seems like it
would be awesome though
if you could take some drug that like
super juiced up your endurance that
sounds
awesome but apparently it's just not
very safe
and they were saying that um a lot of uh
executives
take it now like there's there's people
that are executives that
uh are just entering endurance races and
they're taking epo
and and entering into these endurance
races that like regular people
with regular jobs just decided to take
it
there was some article about that see if
you could find it
it was like ceos uh entering into
in endurance races taking epo
but it's a few fighters have been caught
with it
and it uh apparently just really juices
endurance value like you go 16th round
instead of [ __ ]
yeah type [ __ ] yeah i had a friend that
used to shoot and eat steroids and never
do a push-up
jesus christ he was whacked that's crazy
like go dog
when are you gonna go to the gym next
week
that's insane i'll never forget i'm
seeing him eat like half a bottle of
winnie v
the pink footballs like the pink ones in
the 80s he would just put him in his
hand like tic tacs with a beer
oh my gosh gosh tomorrow i did some
push-ups today
just my biceps that's all i need a few
biceps
italians
crazy group of humans that came over i
always want you to do the impersonation
from you when
italian people in jersey found out that
marlon brando is gay
[Laughter]
i can't [ __ ] believe in 20 years he
was the godfather
and no no no he couldn't blow a regular
dude no god forbid
he blows a black dude to really stab me
right here in the [ __ ] heart i
couldn't even take it no more
i had to throw the dvd collection away
and [ __ ] i would love to hear
one of those guys what they said when
they found out that
that week didn't they say that he [ __ ]
everybody men and women oh yeah he
banged everybody he [ __ ] everybody
yeah
and then it came out he was banging the
guy with the big dick and cube
that's right superman that's right
that's right
so [ __ ] poor italian people if they
were godfather fans
they were lighting those [ __ ] dvds on
fire [ __ ] marlon brando
poor poor homophobes
i like them more now i like marlin
brandon i love
mother brother oh yeah i don't give a
[ __ ] i don't listen
to me richard pryor thinking about
richard pryor getting so coked up that
he let marlon brando [ __ ] him
was one of the things i was like unless
he like that's prejudice of me i should
just assume he enjoyed it
and assumed he enjoyed having sex with
marlon why should i give a [ __ ]
listen listen to me just remember one
thing
because you're gonna die when i tell you
this uh oh marlon brandon
talked the studio into giving them like
a hundred grand to read superman
like you know when people call you up
joe hi joe this is cynthia from your
agents
right we're sending you a script over
for you to approve to read
give me a hundred grand give me a
hundred grand and i'll reset it
he went to the island he went deep he
believed his ego you gotta remember that
was an all-time record for a long time
what he got for superman
he banged him out he took him to the
cleanest time
he [ __ ] him up to the ass bad like big
money he find out what they pay them in
1970 whatever for
superman remember he [ __ ] them big
time um
i think it's mutiny on the bounty on one
of those movies
they kept saying that oh we have a
beautiful spot for you right here in
marina del rio if we do this we gotta do
this on this island i
found he had gone down and fell in love
he's like there's a bunch of running in
the room there's a bunch of women
running around with leaves on
you know what damage i could do
he made the studio shoot down there and
then they never went down there who
wants to go to [ __ ] whatever island
they shot that at so that's where he
lived right
so he went down there he got down and
he's like jamie
what's your job pa no more you're the
director
rogan you're this and everybody was
shooting and they were shooting his feet
they were shooting like him running and
like the shore
and meanwhile he's just banging [ __ ]
hawaiian women
eight at a time just having orgies
banging kids
all those kids that shot themselves all
those kids he had remember
oh my god all those poor kids that
[ __ ] god rest their souls and
all those problems he had he was down
there like [ __ ] just matadorin
whoever paramount whoever the network
was showed up down there and said let's
see the dailies
and said what the [ __ ] is this you're
done
they brought somebody else in marlon
ended up saying [ __ ] it i'll buy the
island
he bought the island didn't he like this
is just crazy [ __ ] i heard over the
years
and they just lived on the island and
then if they wanted
they had to call the island and they had
like levels oh you want me to read the
script that's going to cost you 80.
oh you want me to come to the studio
that's 300 000.
like he had levels of [ __ ] and they
would give it to him they would
and then they didn't want them for the
godfather they were like nah there's no
way we want that [ __ ] guy
wow and then finally he put the tape in
his mouth and all that [ __ ] and they
approved them and
he did up bro that movie is like a porn
the one he did that last tango in paris
is it
that's like a light porn and then the
chick came out years later said that
[ __ ] stone cold raped me
yeah he was the king of me too he
invented me to that
[ __ ] dog wow
yeah she came out years later and said
something about
he she didn't know what marlon brando
went in there
and choked her out like mcqueen and
[ __ ] uh
in the getaway she thought she was just
getting pushed
yeah the mcqueen and who was it with
valley mcgregor
mcgraw that was hard to watch dude
because
you could tell that was real there's no
way that wasn't real
like he was really hitting her there
yeah no no no he was a metal actor
that is harsh he's crazy he was crazy
that scene was so
real because of it i mean it's awful to
watch
but but it's real
right i mean it's an awful scene it's
real
[ __ ] man that imagine being her and all
sudden the dude just starts smacking you
in the head for real
you don't know what to do and you don't
want to bail out of the scene you're
getting [ __ ] up
though he's [ __ ] you up and she
didn't stop
she just kept saying the lines and
working with it
[ __ ] dude jesus christ
what do you say to somebody after that
like hey man i'm sorry but that's what
the scene called for
you can't see i don't know ah
pete it sounds [ __ ] up to say
but i think even just that
recent a time people did not understand
that if you're smacking people in the
head like that you're giving them
[ __ ] brain damage
like you smack someone in the head like
that like you could seriously [ __ ] them
up
like something could be wrong with them
for a long time even if they don't go
unconscious
your mother was smacking that no no my
mom was gonna hit her
really no she wasn't ahead who's mikey
in that
very few people an uncle
no very few people
maybe my grandmother cracked me once but
it was you know
just like getting [ __ ] together not like
trying to hurt me
you know just a little smack i didn't
get beat as a kid
but uh i saw a lot of violence i saw the
seeing violence when you're a kid
there's something about like seeing
uh someone you're close to who's an
adult
being beating up like a 10 or 11 year
old you ever see that before
when you see when you see something like
that you ever see a grown adult
beating the [ __ ] out of a 10 or 11 year
old
when you're a little kid yes that to me
uh was that was like a defining moment
when i was a little kid as a parent
or i only saw parents beat their
children yeah i saw someone beat
somebody else's kid
it was [ __ ] up to watch man when i
lived on 205 west 88th street
we we came when i came from cuba we
lived in jersey for him my dad died we
moved to 89th street
then something happened at the building
and we ended up moving 88th street and i
had a kid i had a beef with every day
and one day i finally got my [ __ ]
together in karate
like one day my sidekick started working
and that [ __ ] right cross started
working
i learned how to use my [ __ ] up block
and
i finally had this kid his name was rudy
the haitian he was the only haitian kid
in the neighbor we lived on 88th street
and i [ __ ] him up this day and his
father came down and held my arms
and he made rudy punch me and i'll never
forget that my lip was bleeding
and he took me upstairs and he knocked
on my mother's door
and my mother opened up the door and
half a [ __ ] hangover and she goes
what's the problem she goes chill with
coco you know
and he goes next time your son hits my
son i'm gonna hit him then i'm gonna
come ahead and hit you
wow and my mom turned around and got a
butcher knife and chased rudy's father
up the stairs
the cops came and the lady next door
said she didn't see a knife
but at that point we were done in the
building
jesus that was one of the worst there
when i moved to north bergen i saw
parents
that you don't like you ever hear a
comedian
go you hang out with white kids you go
to their house how they talk to their
parents
i could never talk about you know right
right that's the first thing i noticed
when i went to jersey there was there
were certain kids that would take their
dish and go
i i don't want tuna fish sandwich if i
ever did that in my house joe rogan
are you [ __ ] kidding me my mom would
take the dish
throw it against the wall and say now
you're not [ __ ] eating go to bed like
that type of [ __ ] but i also
saw a [ __ ] parrot in the hallway one
day that was standing the way you are
with his arms crossed
talking to the teacher the way i'm
talking to you and a kid standing right
here
with glasses on and i'm walking towards
them like you know
i went to the bathroom i had like a hall
pass
and i'm talking talking talking and in
the middle of it the father just going
bam and hitting him with a backhand kick
goes down ugh
glass is broken blood's coming out of
the nose oh
you're telling them to get the [ __ ] up
before i [ __ ] kill you you dumb
[ __ ]
oh you said that to him you dumb [ __ ] i
have seen that oh
that kid was the devil though yeah i
knew that kid well the reason why i knew
that kid
kid was the devil probably because his
dad beat him then there was another kid
when i went to catholic school
guido father ginzo the whole [ __ ]
thing
bro he would come there
the nicest guy in the world but the son
was [ __ ] crazy
and every time he get there the nun
would tell him about what he did
and dog he would punch him
the way
um was throwing punches and got off that
[ __ ] stipe
i i swear his mother's grip christ as he
was crawling into the car
like 400 pounds 12. jesus
10 10 10. i got thrown out of that 11 so
now are you looking at me saying joey
that they deserve it or whatever
everybody every parent had a different
uh you know i watched a couple weeks ago
i was stoned to the gills
and i was laughing about how people put
people down and [ __ ]
and i was laughing about when julia's
serving
first when the aba shut down when the
aba first shut down if they were i don't
know joe but if there was eight
categories
julius irving's led seven of them right
and the aba shut down and the sixers
picked up
servant they gave him six million
dollars which can you imagine that
what would they give that guy yeah what
they give lebron
mr lebron's getting about 30 or 40 but
yeah yeah he got six million dollars for
over two years or something with julius
and he was the biggest player in the
world then
now this guy's getting 154 for three or
so
jesus so dr j switz his number from 32
to 6
and now the nba all-star game came so
all the critics were like
he came from the aba he's gonna get his
ass kicked from the nba
all-star game what go look at those
statistics
he went off he went off because of a
white dude named pistol pete maravich
that is thought he went to lsu and led
the country in scoring a white dude
ended up becoming a [ __ ] boozer but
that dude
knew how to handle the ball because his
father would beat him
his father would make him sleep in the
garage in the winter
and beat him until he learned how to
play basketball
because there was no losing in this
[ __ ] house do you understand me joe
rogan
there's no [ __ ] losers in my
[ __ ] house sleep in the garage no
dinner but pistol pete knew how to
[ __ ] dribble jack
and pistol pete would take you deep
pistol pete could have anybody could
come about
the best black dude in the league could
cover pistol pete
but if you watch that nba all-star game
pistol pete is stopping
chomping people and giving behind the
back passes to julius irving
he even looks at a dude with one path
he's looking at bob mcadoo i'm coming
and honestly he just puts the ball
between his legs and he gives it to
julia julius erving
why because that kid's father stayed on
there's a different thoughts of some
people can handle that some people just
can't though some guys have broken but i
mean it's like how much pressure is too
much pressure to create like a superstar
like that
i did in tiger woods didn't his dad put
a lot of pressure on him as well
let's let's talk about the the the guy
that died last week
but that's a different thing like well
the tiger would joe jackson
what the [ __ ] is different about that he
created three [ __ ] kids to change the
[ __ ] one kid that changed the [ __ ]
world
right he beat him he [ __ ] him in the
air supposedly
i don't know he did sexual assault got
to be really careful with
saying things i'm sorry listen it's the
me too thing things come out what are
you gonna do
everybody's getting to blame for
something you know what i'm saying but
this is something you really heard
i have i've heard sexual abuse
allegations from his father but
but i listen to listen to what what did
he create
what did he do what did joe jackson do
by making them
not letting them [ __ ] uh and let me
tell you something the one kid could
have gone to a college to play
basketball
the kids had talent as it was gary
indiana here we go carrie indiana
no it's like hell
uh [ __ ] delaware and then gary
indiana
like you know saying like gary's like
crazy
he made these kids rehearse he pulled
them out of gary took him up to [ __ ]
barry gordy
you know you think about this [ __ ] some
of them probably hated him for what he
did
you look back at those lessons that you
got your rogue and how many people
did you look at one day and go [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
but then two years later you look back
and you look at the lesson you learned
from the whole experience
and you actually have to go back and hug
that person and go hey man
thank you for that time it made me
better [ __ ] today because of
what you did
made me a better person we're not going
to agree with everything that happens
along the way joe wrong
but it's made us who the [ __ ] we are
today that's an interesting thing
because
we grew up in a time where uh kids were
just allowed to run around outside
everybody ran around outside that was
just normal
right when you were a little kid you ran
around outside
nobody just runs around outside i
remember the first time i saw a grown
lady hit she hit my cousin
we were both around the same age i was
probably
six and she was five and this lady
slipped on ice in front of her apartment
building
and she got up and my cousin just
unfortunately happened to be standing
right in front of her when she fell
and she got up and she said don't you
laugh at me and she smacked her in the
face
she wasn't laughing at her either just
she smashed her in the face man like it
was
she smacked her hard and i was like oh
my god
was that i mean we were both little
little kids and watching some
grown adult smash our cousin
in the face we're like like
you just gotta realize like hey you
can't you know
you got to be polite there's some
[ __ ] people that will smack you in
the face and she didn't even do anything
wrong
there's some evil [ __ ] out there
that'll hit little kids
that's some dark [ __ ] man smacking
little kids in the face
i swear to god i ran into probably
when i first moved from cuba to 88th
street there was a dude on the block
that would smack little kids
and i'm telling you right now to my
little daughter
there was words on the street that he
would take it through his house with
[ __ ] the ass
oh my goodness that's how great this is
this is the early 70s
this was the early 70s which i turned
into a joke later on
because it would be like bro have you
seen joe rogan lately
nah i haven't seen him in a week sticky
charlie guy i'm like
a sticky charm what was his name mr
martini mr martinez mr martini got him
like when you first moved to 88th street
that's the first thing the kids would
tell you
like i was keeping away from this guy
don't [ __ ] with mr martini
oh jesus he's a monster in his
neighborhood he wore a black suit
with a white shirt and black shoes his
wife would die
and he owned a building on 88th street
in the middle
and he was angry and he would sweep and
you know like when you were
a kid and you stopped in front of
somebody's house he would always come
out and go get the [ __ ] out of here you
little
[ __ ] douchebags get the [ __ ] and i
was cuban i didn't understand the
language
i didn't really understand what he was
saying i understood the anger
but i didn't understand the language and
he would come out with a broom get the
[ __ ] out of here
one day i realized i'm like this
[ __ ] wants to rock
so while my other friends didn't want to
[ __ ] with them i'm like we're gonna [ __ ]
with this [ __ ]
so all cubans have like water in front
of their house and there's something
that your mother throws changing every
day
yeah it's like a good luck statue and i
would steal the change
and bring it downstairs and i would look
at the poorer kids and i'd go come here
for a second
you want to call it and they would go
yeah we'll get a quarter and i would
take a quarter and throw it
where mr martini lived he lived like in
the basement area
he ran the whole bed he'd be right there
and he'd chase us we go mr martini suck
my weenie and he's [ __ ] jesus
and jesus christ oh my god if he caught
you
he would [ __ ] hit you like 50 times
but we [ __ ] him up we would [ __ ] him
up
dog i saw some [ __ ] the first day
like new jersey to me was a completely
that was like mars to most people like
most people listen to
me and go you grew up someplace that
doesn't exist
i'll bring eight people to fill these
chairs to tell you about the parents and
the people
and the situations but the first day i
went out in my hometown of north bergen
i saw me and joe rogan fight
and even though i had joe rogan on his
back i saw joe rogan's father come down
the stairs
pull me off joe rogan smack me punch me
kick me throw me on the floor and make
his kids go in
that was my first experience ever in
north bergen new jersey i saw
mr robson come downstairs he took
anthony off his son
threw him off smacked him in the [ __ ]
face
joe rogan at two in the after [ __ ]
noon
in 90 degree heat punched him in the
stomach and told him to go home you
little giddy [ __ ]
go home you little guinea [ __ ] say that
now they'll throw you in jail for
two years he told him go home you little
guinea [ __ ] and
anthony looked at him crying a little
bit he picked up his shirt he went like
this
like he took the thing off and he goes
i'm calling my [ __ ] father
you're [ __ ] dead [ __ ] oh your
[ __ ] guinea [ __ ] grease ball
father god i dare you
he's probably a grease ball just like
you and i'm sitting there going
i want to see how this plays out
and next thing you know two cop cars
pull up
and it's one cop car that's unmarked
that's another one that's marked
and it's a big [ __ ] italian looking
detective like you know
the short stumpy italian and he comes
out of his car he puts his [ __ ]
jacket on it barely fits but till this
dare i remember the mortadelles he had
on his hand
and he goes what the [ __ ] is going on
here kids and the little italian kid
comes when he goes miss
this [ __ ] mr robson came down here
and he [ __ ] smacked me in the face
these are my witnesses tell him didn't
he [ __ ] hit me and i'm sitting there
going
oh this is gonna get [ __ ] good
and the next you know the the [ __ ]
cop
the detective tells the cop go look
around see if there's tickets
go spread tickets and he goes where's
this guy live
and he goes yeah and he goes he grabbed
all the other kids and he goes tell me
what happened
and he goes anthony and him were
fighting and he came down here and he
[ __ ] pulled him and now at this time
they know that
the cops are there and mr robson i kind
of opened this door to be kind of tough
like he's not coming up he's gonna know
i'm gonna [ __ ] knock him out too
and the cop goes okay okay okay and he
grabbed the kid and goes you're okay
right
yeah because he just hit me in the face
and he [ __ ] walked up the stairs bro
took him five minutes
got to the top thing guy opened the
[ __ ] door
jorog and this guy put his hand in
pulled them out [ __ ] put him against
the [ __ ] thing on the second floor
with everybody out
and just started punching him oh
punching him
punching him like [ __ ]
john jones when he's got you down he's
hitting you with those shots to the head
until the guy killed over and he started
kicking him with the [ __ ] thing
damn bam bam and that daddy goes don't
you
ever [ __ ] hit my son again let's get
out of here
and that was how i became friends with
the family
because as soon as he came down he goes
who's this kid he goes he's this big kid
he's the only one that jumped in
he goes you want to come over for dinner
and that was the beginning of my life
when i got in that police car wow
because i did crazy whatever i did
whatever the [ __ ] i want look at this
till today
this is [ __ ] crazy and you know me
and you don't [ __ ] around
what do you got over there this is still
that's what happened in 1970 [ __ ]
three
and what's that today that's a a gold
card
what does this card do it it does what
it will need it to do it does whatever i
needed to do you know what i'm saying
you're a family member why because of
that [ __ ] day because i'm the only
guy that jumped in
i like how cops have things like that a
family member you could also
see every card you could get from one of
your buddies who's a cop
show this you ever get pulled over put
this on your license plate look at this
little sneaky little thing
so now we're tight i'm eating at the
house i'm eating [ __ ] pasta
with fresh mozzarella in the middle oh i
could open up the front door whenever i
want i call them mama she makes cream
puffs
oh wow so i'm tight with them i'm the
only cuban in 1974 that's even walking
in there
so now we're in the sixth grade and
we're playing kickball mckinley had no
[ __ ]
remember two months ago ellen degeneres
donated 50 000 to a grammar school it
was my grammar school in north bergen
new jersey
about two months ago yeah ellen
degeneres donated 50
000 now when i went to that grammar
school those [ __ ] didn't have a
gym joe
shovel snow they gotta be
shoveled snow you shovel snow when it
snowed out you shovel snow
that was part of your physical education
yeah and you did push-ups and sit-ups
and [ __ ] that's like russian [ __ ] bro
and they had a [ __ ] bar
in the in the kitchen where you didn't
pull ups no no they were brutal
finally they built the gym in the eighth
grade yeah but before that
we played kickball outside in the fall
when they were king playing kickball
i'll never forget this the guy's name
was mr tortora
that was the teacher's name was he a
good guy he was a good freaking little
jim teacher
and we're out there we're playing
kickball and again that little italian
kid
the one that invited me to his house his
father beat up the [ __ ] dude
we're playing kickball and he's throwing
the ball and every time i swing
and i miss he's calling me goku kademoko
that means
i'm a boogie face in spanish because it
rhymes with coco
right and the teacher keeps going
anthony i told you a thousand times
none of that shit's allowed you know
this is this is the sixth grade north
bergen new jersey
mr tatara was like hey none of that
spicaroo [ __ ] over here right this is
america
right really oh bro that was at that
time that was a big issue because
a couple weeks before that a guy named
kotora was a baseball
coach and he threw a kid off for
speaking spanish on the bus
he told him he was no spanish on the bus
and the kid goes [ __ ] you and he spoke
spanish and he threw him off like
20 miles from the house became a big
problem in my hometown
they're gonna kill the [ __ ] dude but
i remember going home my mom going
he's talking the truth
and now she speaks spanish this is
america outside you speak america
so my mom cut me off right there like i
went home like ready to [ __ ] be like
a protester
and she was like that don't happen here
we're americans you want to talk spanish
talking in the house
i think there's a real benefit to being
able to speak more than one language
definitely is yeah completely different
mindset
i'm happy i do it i speak to my daughter
in spanish
if i tell my ask mercy something
i re-ask her in spanish if i tell the
scientists i really
yeah they say that things like that
they're learning
new languages in particular opens up
parts of your brain
that if you're just a dummy like me that
only speaks english you can access
different just different ways of looking
at things
you know well it's very analytical let's
say you wanted to be a lawyer
one of your pre whatever would be a
language
right you'd also have a heavy math
to be a lawyer you have to have a very
heavy math
pre-curriculum yeah a lot of history you
probably end up being a history major
but there'd be a lot of math a lot of
econ a lot of analytics
because it forces your mind to solve
equations
so when if you look at the prerequisites
whatever the [ __ ] it is what's the
prerequisites prerequisites
to be an attorney there's a lot of math
involved interesting there's got to be
language involved there's got to be
politics involved like
american political systems american
history systems
all that [ __ ] but it's got to be heavy
math
once you get to law school it's heavy
reading and
but before that it's a lot of problem
solving yeah
that's the that's how you become a
problem solver by [ __ ]
uh whatever yeah i agree with you
whatever you just said well before i got
locked up i was planning to be an
attorney so i was a really
a history major yeah that's that was the
[ __ ]
plan and then then thank god for history
podcasts
i love them they're the best i was
thinking of going back to school
no no no no no no no no there's no
reason just listen and refresh and then
go on and read about it well there's
books on tape too that you listen to
that are great but uh hardcore history
and
hardcore is great you ever listened to
my boy daniel
history on fire his [ __ ] is fantastic
he was telling me about this road to
rome i've never forgot this image
where there was i think something like
150 miles of
bodies that were put on stakes
he sent it to me he just sent it to me a
couple of days ago 150
miles of of human bodies
that they stuck on these
big poles and shoved them into the
ground
for my like every 30 yards they put a
new person's body here it is
125 miles with one body crucified every
30 yards or so for a total of
about 6 000 people crucified on the road
between
kapua and rome what
the [ __ ] what was your purpose
i would have to go back and listen to it
again i forgot so that's a shadow one
here
whoo that shit's intense i want to start
with uh i'm going to start from
zero i'm going to start with the
mongolians and
listen wrath of the khan dan carlin the
greatest
podcast ever and then i want to move on
to american history oh he's going to
101 i need american history
101 day one we're going back to roots
let's go from roots let's go to 1776
what happened all there i need all that
refreshed
yeah all that stuff needs to be
dude carlin has got some phenomenal
stuff on world war one
let's cover both wars let's cover both
wars let's cover the third war of
vietnam
and let's cover the [ __ ] whatever the
the conflict
all that [ __ ] i was doing comedy so who
watches the news
i don't know who the [ __ ] was watching
the news in 1991 not me
i didn't watch tv again till you know
2003 or something like that i didn't
watch the [ __ ] news and have a chance
to be inclined politically or what the
[ __ ] was going on i was just worried
about doing stand-up
right
this silence brought to you by marijuana
i didn't no no i didn't know i thought
he was looking for something or whatever
i'm ready to [ __ ] go you know me
though you are we got a great [ __ ]
card this week we could [ __ ] break
down no you broke it down with brendan
i gotta tell you man i like uh i'm
leaning and i love dan cormier he's a
[ __ ] champion of champions he took a
[ __ ] couple
bombs from anthony johnson bombs from
anthony johnson
but jesus christ every time they put an
obstacle in front of stipe's way
he figures out a way to take it down you
know yeah he's hell-bent on staying
champion he's a giant dude
like stipe is a big guy and i know
that daniel has beaten every single
heavyweight he's fought he's undefeated
as a heavyweight and
including like throwing josh barnett
around who's just a beast
but uh stipe is a as the the most
accomplished heavyweight champion of all
time
that's just a fact he defended his title
against the top contenders and did it
successfully three times nobody else
been able to do that
or take uh holloway jesus christ
well he fights both fights of jesus
christ [ __ ] great
a dc fight is a fascinating fight
fascinating fights
wrestler and steep a is
i mean he's as good as it gets we're
doing the show friday night g yeah we're
doing me and uh ian are doing the mirage
okay beautiful yeah it should be fun
nice
yeah you ready for it yeah man i'm
excited i'm excited for this card
it should be it should be very
interesting what's going on with you in
the running lately you're really digging
it
yeah i'm digging it but i have a little
bit of a tear in my meniscus
are you thinking of if you fix the
meniscus of doing something
with running like running what your
buddy does those
marathons oh no have you considered
something like that
not really man i'm not i don't i'm not
into doing something that i know
is hard to do and it's definitely not
good for your body
i just think you get beat up doing that
[ __ ] i'm going to just take your friend
i mean as good as she jammer's a
different kind of human well he needs
that in some ways they take him to
recover from something like that
well that's an interesting thing you
just a good good time for that question
because he just ran a race today he ran
like a six mile race
and he was saying that his legs are not
fully recovered
he was saying in the post that you know
his cardio was really good but
you gotta figure you run for 24 hours
i mean he ran for 24 hours just
a month ago right was it a month ago not
even a month ago three weeks ago
something like that um that [ __ ] takes
time and he's 50.
you know when you're 50 years old it's
not as uh the recovery is
the recovery is is very tough yeah he's
an animal
but he lives to push himself like that
you know i'm
more inclined to try to preserve my body
i like pushing myself but i'm just
a chicken [ __ ] i don't want to be i
don't want to be breaking hips and
knees and [ __ ] my brother just had
shoulder surgery eddie bravo
he just got the stitches out this is his
second surgery that he's had
just this year you know he had um he had
knee surgery
real recently like a few months ago
right didn't he have his meniscus done a
few months ago this generation of jiu
jitsu guys
is learning a lot and they're learning
what they're going to pass on to the
next generation is that it's great to
roll and the leg locks are great and all
that is great
but there's another aspect to this this
which is called yoga and keeping your
muscles strong
yeah and the conditioning has to be good
and you're
uh you know there's also curious wear
and tear yeah
let's just take care of yourself a
little these these guys didn't know you
didn't know
no you didn't know well it took me a
while to learn but yeah the reality
of jiu-jitsu is it's a thing that as you
get older you have to be much more
careful
who you train with and how you train you
can't just go balls to the wall like you
could when you were 27
you have to keep your [ __ ] together and
you know
injuries are real you can't just work
through them
like that was a big fallacy people would
get hurt and they would try to roll
light nobody ever rolls a light
they always say they're gonna roll light
and then the guy almost gets you and
you're trying to get him next thing you
know you're defending and it's [ __ ]
serious heated up
roll session which is great but then
you're like ah
like your neck's all [ __ ] up and you
go all right next guy i'm just gonna lay
on my back and work my half guard
[ __ ] as soon as it starts getting
hot and heavy you almost got caught in
an arm bar then you try to pop up and
then try to pass his guard
then you get into it you know it's uh
it's a thing that's too exciting
you know and jiu jitsu uh when i say
like rolling hard
i don't mean like
not even breaking my level no no no
listen me passing your guard
and laying on you that's not funny
that's a tough morning
yeah even though i'm giving your love on
top joking you breathe yeah yeah i'm
good joey
i'm letting you i'm just not letting you
get the underhook i
give tons of love when i i i love it
yeah i'm addicted to it it's changed who
i am
you know i had to attack it from a
different foundation
i was attacking it from looking at jamie
and going
i got to do what jamie does and not
realizing i got jamie by 25 years and i
can't do what jamie does
so my game has to be completely
different to jamie's
mondays when i come into class it's more
about the uh
the the uh drilling unless about the
rolling
and i'll do an hour conditioning class
with brett
we do everything we do the ball the
things the ropes
i do everything and i'll do that jujitsu
class but i'll do the drills
i'll roll once or twice and papa's got
to go thursday
i go balls to the wall on the rolling
which means three or four rows
that's awesome and then i try to take
friday off and then sat out the
way time condition and i'm done for the
week joey diaz getting fit
you got to do it i got this
five-year-old number two i
i watched your thing and i really do it
i go to [ __ ] cryotherapy and i put my
head in there
i go to u.s cryotherapy i'm a novathor
guy too
that bed is making me feel [ __ ]
phenomenal what is it
i'm getting tremendous hard irons what
is it the novathor bed
the bed that you lay on and it cleans
out your cells and [ __ ] like that what
does it do
it does everything look it up it's a
[ __ ] animal you understand me
plus i get in that freezer for three
minutes and 30 seconds i put madonna on
burn enough for your love i went to gay
pride i forgot all about the gates look
at this thing
thinner fitter healthier happier what is
it tremendous
this is the dude they're going to talk
us into getting into a pod
the next thing you know you're going to
be locked into the
into the matrix what so what is this
treatment
no negative side effects clients are
supply supplied with
safety goggles and then relax into
novothor
treatment prod for eight to fifteen
minutes of whole body restorative light
treatment the treatment may be repeated
two
or more times a week what is it doing
it's not saying what it's done what like
what he's gonna instigate the [ __ ]
thing
he's gonna look into it what are you
bothering me for
tell me why i should get in your light
box it's a whole body delivery system of
pbm
therapy that has been designed to
deliver optimal
wavelengths power what is that word
densities
and dosages based on the published
clinical research
outcomes huh i can't read from here
where's the whole body in just six to 15
minutes the intended use of novothor
or to redevelop muscles or restore
motion to joints
or for use as an adjunct therapy for
obesity
that seems like it does a lot of [ __ ] i
don't know
is that real i'm trying to hang on is
that real jamie do i look okay
you look good all right then you're
exactly [ __ ] you feel like you're
moving good
like you're losing weight yeah no you
have to do something
yeah all that training you're doing if
you're doing that much training that's
crazy
that's really awesome i really love it
though that's beautiful and i try to do
one strength training at the house
honest style
with club bells if you want to come here
man we'll i'll work you out we'll work
out together seriously i was thinking
about calling you and coming around yeah
maybe you give me a kickboxing lesson
for sure and you know what else we could
do we could do like a circuit a
circuitry yeah because i have that uh
echo air bike
you know that echo bike i've never done
that it's phenomenal
so we could do uh rose the echo bike and
i got a versa climber and i like to do
them
in i do those tabata sequences so it's
like you
you go hard for 20 seconds and then you
rest for 10 seconds then you go hard for
20 seconds and you rest for 10 and you
do like eight
rounds of those it's [ __ ] intense and
then you jump on over to the row machine
the row machines
there's another one a similar number
it's like 30 hot
30 hard 30 off something like that and
then you go to the versa climber and you
plug in
you turn 50 yeah yeah yeah i'm 50. you
know i'm almost 51. i'll be 51.
it's uh it's really interesting what
i've learned
and what i've read about 50. i saw a
picture of carol o'connor
a year ago when he was 46 years old when
he was doing
all right she bunker 46 46
jesus 40 seconds whoa go to that
give me a picture of archie this is when
he stopped or when he started
i don't know it was a picture of him at
46.
and i was like there has to be a better
way let me see that i saw
holy [ __ ] you know this is what america
that is crazy
what did you look like at 46 and 47.
and you were like look at that dude he
looked
like well maybe that was like in the
later years
there's a funny thing right the lovable
racist
he was like the last of like he
represented a real guy that might have
had
racist views that were kind of funny
and he was in some way endearing because
he was like such a
good actor and it was such a good
character and was so well
written and his relationship with his
wife and his kids and with meathead
i mean the whole thing was it was a
brilliant show
like such a well-crafted show when sammy
davis kissed him on the lips
when [ __ ] when he found the puerto
ricans dude
in the wallet and the puerto rican guy
comes over there talking
and he looks at his wife in front of
puerto rico he goes alice
don't just stand there off him or
something and she goes i don't know what
he likes and he goes
i don't know what puerto ricans drink
and he looks at him the guy's smiling
i'm like
and you look something like i don't know
puerto ricans drink he goes
i don't know how about some pineapple
juice
you know what i'm saying the guy looks
like that you get thrown off the
air today yeah but it was it wasn't
hateful racism it was
queen's racism well first of all
pineapple juice is delicious and why is
it racist
that a dude from an island would want
some pineapple juice i would think that
would you would be
like culturally sensitive to like
introduce that possibility like if i
said
something that you're you have a
tradition of drinking pineapple today's
society if i said to you listen i'm
leaving here i'm going to chinatown they
got fireworks
if somebody heard me said to you right
now to to tomorrow we'd get [ __ ]
yeah we'd have a problem i would have a
problem yeah well everybody knows that
20 years ago right now i'd be heading to
chinatown and new york city getting
[ __ ] amount of fireworks
144 bottle rockets a couple roman
candles
you know what's the most stupid man is
that the food
is somehow racist like there's
there's food that's racist food like if
you talked about black people and also
talked about delicious fried chicken
or delicious orange soda or grape soda
would be grape soda right
not orange soda orange sodas white
people yeah orange soda is a white
people thing right
white trash orange soda no is that i
don't know
not that i'm anti-orange soda but i'm
saying like those foods like watermelon
in particular if you
talk about a black person and you talk
about watermelon that's
a racist term even though watermelon's
delicious
it's [ __ ] weird like what is what the
hell could be wrong about watermelon
if you don't like the taste of
watermelon if it's a hot summer day
and somebody busts open a cooler and
gives you a slice of watermelon how
[ __ ]
pumped are you how could watermelon ever
be negative
that don't make any sense to me it makes
zero sense
and the only way it makes sense that
fried chicken could be negative to you
is if you're a vegan or a vegetarian you
don't want to eat a chicken
that's the only way it makes sense that
that would be a negative
because otherwise like fried chicken is
[ __ ] delicious who doesn't like fried
chicken
if you eat meat fried chicken is
something you smell it
you oh someone's really good at making
it and they got a nice
flaky layer on the outside you bite into
that juicy perfectly cooked chicken
least fried chicken in tennessee jesus
joseph
spices and [ __ ] tennessee a little
leaves fried chicken
jesus christ there's places that know
how to do some fried chicken
how could that be bad how could that
ever be racist
i that doesn't make any sense we gotta
let that go
i'm gonna tell you a racist thought but
not really like saturday i went to the
park with my daughter i'm sitting there
and i saw a hasidic jew
on sunday with the beanie and his wife
with glasses
i was just sherman oaks and he had a ten
dollar bill sticking out of his pocket
and i wanted to work my [ __ ]
pickpocketing skills i wanted to see if
i could still pickpocket a [ __ ]
i even have my daughter bumping into his
leg and stuff you can't pickpocket a jew
dog you can't do it dude
you know when i was a kid that was my
first [ __ ] dream
to pickpocket the children i watched a
movie with our boy in it and michael
cyruson who the first pickpocket movie
is called harry in your pocket
with our boy in your flint and like
flint james coburn
james colburn was in a pickpocket oh
nobody knows about it america's greatest
secret
and they would work airports and [ __ ]
like that harry in your pocket
so i hunted down my mom i used to hear
them talk about this cuban
pickpocket guy in cuba in the 50s
yeah yeah tremendous what did you do
with him you did something with him
right
yeah i did two things with him i did
american gun with him
and i did uh our list with him all this
is up you can find on others it's online
somebody just posted the wallet
i forgot about our list that's one of
those shows that i forgot about but i
watched him and i asked this guy how do
you become a pickpocket
i bumped into him at a cuban joint there
was a rumor going around that he was a
good cuber
pickpocketing cube and he goes you gotta
get a dummy
and put bells on the pockets so i went
and i don't know how i got a little
dummy and i put bells on in
[ __ ] years i tried to be a pickpocket
but i have big hands
yeah you gotta have those slender things
you gotta have to slend the fingers
pockets and you bump into them and [ __ ]
i'm very light-footed that i am i was a
good burglar
because i could tiptoe you know what i'm
saying that's from my ears a tip tone on
the dummy
to try to take the wallet from the dummy
i could just never [ __ ] pick back in
the dummy
it's great that you're doing so many
different things though it's really cool
to hear
you're rolling you're doing some muay
thai and the rolling has really improved
because
at first you can't roll i i dropped the
weight because
i figured for every five pounds it'd be
a little bit more cardio
plus i got the boss rooting mouthpiece i
spoke to him yesterday again you like
that thing huh
i really believe in it i don't know what
if you use it while you're working out
or
i use it when i walk you're walking when
i walk i take a walk in the morning 20
30 minutes
explain to people what it is the the
boss root and mouthpiece is on amazon
that's
his webpage i saw it because he was on
joe
talking about it i was having such a
struggle with my breathing i was having
such a struggle
but it was just common sense number one
i smoked cigarettes for 20 years number
two
i smoked reefer for 40 years but all
those are just excuses
the number one thing was the weight
every [ __ ] fan inside
is some smart guy said handsome bastard
yeah he's such a hand that's a
[ __ ] handsome mother he's a
great guy too
he's one of the best people i know some
guys say to me that great guy
a great brown belt told me that whenever
he rolls
he could feel the difference when he's
10 pounds heavy oh yeah for sure goes oh
joy whenever i go to my mother's and i
come back that first week it's
brewing like oh really and i go so
if i'm walking around at 309 trying to
be [ __ ] heady
it's not going to work so i just started
chopping on the weight i went back to
weight watchers
i walked in there at 3 10. i heard they
have a bunch of different rules now
like what you can eat what you can't eat
i'm going to tell you something you can
eat as many eggs
cause you know you and i always have
this conversation
if you're heavy and you don't go to
weight watchers it's because you're a
[ __ ] loser
whoa that's a it's that it's that easy
it's that easy because i'm an idiot i
mean you enjoy it
i'm a [ __ ] idiot here papa here papa
come on that's my guide
okay that's my guide so you uh put
everything you eat into this app
into the app oh nice okay it comes with
that let me show you what i was like
dinner snacks total
and then you uh you count it out by
points is that what they do
they do it themselves how many points
you get in a day 39. now let's say
joey would you eat that give me that can
of coffee um
right there don't give me that one pop
up if you don't mind pink
okay we don't know so you scan that and
then it'll
tell you how many i don't think that has
many calories in it does coffee plain
coffee have calories
not really maybe a couple but not really
so when you get the [ __ ] milkshake
coffees for breakfast
and the [ __ ] uh flat white even a
flat white don't kill you all right this
isn't in there
it's not in there but you go like this
boom and then you got this joe rogan you
ready
you press this over here and you press
this here
and you press this here and they give
you points for whatever you do
walk circuit training then you have
custom so i press
brazilian jiu jitsu let's you go to an
hour class how much do you really
[ __ ] roll
15 minutes if you go to an hour class
you're doing technique he teaches you
how to do the drill
and he tells you a joke so you're
pressing 15
done and then you press the intensity
where you breathe like an atom i just
bent seven points
you leave this in your phone in your
pocket you put this in your pocket
and [ __ ] guess what happens it counts
the steps when i went to disneyland that
i burnt 31 [ __ ] points
so it's all the eggs i could eat for
breakfast so for breakfast i go to
john's and i gotta
see the roll even if i give myself four
[ __ ] points for the row five points
for the roll six points for a row
i put two eggs in that [ __ ]
which is 14 grams of protein
and i put a thin slice of humans boys
had american cheese
and some frank's hot sauce on that
[ __ ] how are you going to talk
to me
what do you want to talk to me about so
you essentially could eat anything you
want
as long as you know what the points are
i can get a certain amount of points
fish i can out fish you for days
so i'll leave here and go to [ __ ]
sushi dan and i get the crunchy albacore
which is i can't wait for rogan to visit
me it's sliced albacore
covered with jalapenos onion and garlic
is it possible let me ask you this is it
possible that you could eat just all
eggs all day
and have zero points zero points really
eggs all day scrambled eggs all day that
sounds crazy
fish all day sea bass you could eat
salmon and sea bass
all day chicken breasts no skin no skin
all [ __ ] day all day chicken
breasts
not chicken cutlets like mom made with
italian
bread crumbs no no no no no that's fried
grilled chicken on a breast with red
crushed peppers and a baked potato
five points for the baked potato whoo
so you want to tell me again how uh
listen
it's not a journey it's not a [ __ ]
race see before
it's only healthy to lose like a pound a
pound and a half a week
is that what it is that's what it was
that's what they say anything after that
you're going into that loser show where
they lost all that
weight at one shot and then that's why
all these
diets and stuff that you have to do on
something that you're gonna do forever
i've always liked this i lost 100 pounds
with this
yeah and then i gained 40 and now i lost
another 30.
that's awesome and it hasn't been
killing me like i don't miss nothing
you know when i learned i didn't know
this i would go get an acai bowl
america thinks salazar ebola is great
let me explain something to you
eating a banana and putting a banana in
a blender
is two different things i did not know
that
one day i was making one of those
because i switch i have on it protein
which i use the vanilla or the chocolate
mexican chocolate
and then i have this other one that's a
paleo type protein it's coconut
milk and i put i used that one and one
day i said let me put a banana in this
[ __ ] just to see and i'm like
damn this is delicious i'm on to
something
i gained weight that week i didn't know
what it was from the banana
when you blend the banana it's eight
points
what when you eat a banana it's who gods
but it's zero coffee because when you
eat fruit
and when you drink fruit it's two
different things that's why we're all
these fat people when you see them going
i don't eat breakfast i drink a smoothie
you're killing yourself you were killing
yourself every time you puree fruit
because when you eat fruit the sativa
that's the saliva saliva
the saliva in your mouth breaks the
fruit down and it digests the
sugar a different way when you bypass
that
enzyme in your mouth that's when you get
300 pounds like uncle joey
right so when you drink fruit i don't
care if they tell you oh it's frozen
fruit you lose some of the sugar
that's [ __ ] once you [ __ ] blend
that fruit
you dead because it goes right into your
system it goes out to you
down all the fiber yeah
you're not supposed to learn that [ __ ]
any other way other than the way that it
comes
when you eat it you could go to that
[ __ ] little mexican stand
with the umbrellas you ever see those
guys the cartel delivery
is that what that is yeah that's what
the cartel drops off that money shake
them down they got 300 000 under that
guy's over there cutting fruit with a
machete go ahead i dare you to go up
there
when you see a cartel umbrella that's a
cartel money
that they got tons of money in those
things they just confuse people
they even got them across the street
from one another
well that's starbucks don't you think
they're just poor people that are trying
to make some money
not really how many apples you gotta
sell the [ __ ] pay rent in this
days and times nobody stands out there
look at those mexicans they don't even
use spf
they're out there raw with no [ __ ]
umbrella out there yeah they look
darker than dark they get dark you know
but you got to pay me to stand out there
all [ __ ] day in this weather a lot
they don't
they get like 200 a day 300 a day not
because they're cutting apples up
because the guy comes to name pancho and
takes what's underneath them
and takes it straight to mexico on
thursdays and nobody sees nothing
that every time you eat that fruit it's
sprinkled with cocaine eat some of that
fruit
no watch the energy you get like that
box of royal florida can't they just be
poor farmers
because that's outside of the room
because that's how nice people like you
think for me i'm a criminal
i see people for what it is i see things
for what it is
i'm trying to sell the lead to a rehab
because are you i got a friend that's
got a rehab you go down there lee why
are you trying to sell lee sell
send lee to him because he can make
money there's a rehab there's a bunch of
rehabs in florida you go to
and they get your insurance and they
bang your insurance for 60 and then they
give you a cup back at 30.
i totally let me send you down into my
buddies give me ten percent i get three
grand
you go down they get acupuncture they
give you a few massages how do you give
a [ __ ]
oh the rehab business imagine who lisa
would be
in terms of his marijuana consumption
imagine where he would be
if it wasn't for you like there is that
guy
when you first started having him on
your show when you guys first started
doing youtube
pop maybe three times in college
a couple months in he's done superhero
doses of edibles
couple months in i mean like little by
little little by little but when you
would sneak them in on them
and you would take away a 250 and put it
to 500. what i would do is wrap it i get
this
this the joey diaz
co-star in the church of what's
happening now is completely asleep at
the wheel
he's on the show and his eyes are almost
totally closed he's
barely a slit and he's just dazed
who's the guest who is that it's raymond
bozzia
a kid that i told on this podcast
yeah he can't take him though hi
what is the name of this video jamie lee
and out of space
elisa in outer space
look at him go he's gone i would get
these
okay i would go over there in the
afternoons and i would get a 180 and i
would rip the cover off to 180.
and i would take a 67 60 milligram woman
i'd eat that one it was like two in the
afternoon
they don't do nothing to me i'd eat like
a 60 and i'd take the 180 and put in the
60 rapper
oh no and then i'd bring it to him put
it on the table
and in front of him i go here and then
open it up for him and he wouldn't see
that it was half
opened already uh and i would give him
the 60.
but it was like last night i gave him an
expired one it had a little bit of mold
on it
he he's going to be a good comic a bro
he is going to be a good cop
look at eleanor eleanor sat there for 15
years
shut her mouth and watched
there's a really special gift to that
yeah
whether you think eleanor was funny or
not whether you agree with her or not i
give her the balls
a lot of people don't like just sitting
there and watching
there's a lot of people that do though
you know there's a lot of people that
work
in and around comedy clubs that probably
want to do it they just don't know how
to get started
you know they just don't have it in them
to get the ball rolling
it's hard it's hard to it's hard to try
something new you keep thinking about
when's the right time to do it is it now
maybe should i wait a week you know you
know what i'm going to lose 10 pounds
and then i'm going to try it
and you get all these things in your
head how long did it take you seriously
honest honest honest engine
well my birthday was august 11th
and uh when i turned 21 was august 11th
of 2000 and or 1988 rather
so i got on stage august 27th so
from my birthday to when i got on stage
it was just a few days
it was just the quickest terrified
terrified
i was trying to check it out um jonathan
katz was the
emcee and i was maybe going to get up it
was one of those things or
signed up for the list you know you get
i think it was five minutes and there's
a bunch of people that are gonna do five
minutes
and jonathan katz who was already an
established stand-up comedian
he really funny guy and he was the host
and uh he's like um
he came up to me he said um let me check
in a half an hour in to see if i can get
young
sometimes people wouldn't show up and so
a half an hour in
um i'm thinking i'm just gonna chicken
out i'm just gonna bail
i'm just gonna tell them forget about it
and when i'm thinking this in my head i
walked up to him and he's i got you in
joe
so uh you'll be going up right here and
you'll have five minutes
good luck and i said all right thank
thanks man
okay so i was ready to [ __ ] out dude i
was totally ready to [ __ ] out
and i was so nervous the first time i
went on stage i was [ __ ] terrified i
couldn't believe it was the name of the
place
stitches stitch's comedy club august 27
1988. um i was terrified dude
terrified i couldn't believe i was
scared i didn't it didn't make any sense
to me i didn't think i was going to be
scared
i thought maybe i'd be like a little
nervous like i'd never performed before
so this idea of doing it i was like well
you know i've taught
taekwondo classes in front of people
before i can talk in front of people
and then i thought about the idea of
like doing stand-up in front of people
what the [ __ ]
made this go down there it took me it's
crazy it took me
a year to think about it and then it
snowed
and i couldn't go to work because we
can't roof
colorado right so i rented a punchline
oh tom hanks and sally fields
angel salazar damon wayans yeah
bunch of people in that movie i watched
punchline
and that pissed me the [ __ ] off
like that was it i went on the yellow
pages i found
comedy clubs i called them and comedy
works offered a
tuesday night open mic how do i get on
you have to call in and they'll give you
three minutes
okay so for two months i called in
nothing and then one night they're like
joe diaz
and i called him back that night oh my
god i'm sick
i got the flu i was like i'm not going
down there wow
and then i was roofing i'm roofing i'm
roofing i'm roofing i'm estimating jobs
i'm going to different jobs and dropping
off material i had like two crews
working and i went to one crew and they
go hey man
we're stuck here on this job can you get
us the morning break
and i go yeah i'll go over there and i
went over to this little diner right off
the [ __ ]
30 whatever that i-70 mm-hmm
it's like 70 or i-25 which one the one
in denver
it was like an industrial area trucks
everywhere
i don't remember what the number that
road is we were doing a road there and i
but there was a place around the corner
jamie
dad the best [ __ ] green chili you
ever had in your [ __ ] life and when
you poured them over [ __ ] scrambled
eggs your dick would get [ __ ] harder
than
[ __ ] with two tortillas are you kidding
me to eat
those [ __ ] two huevos rancheros i
walk
over there i sit down and you know
there's always a paper
like in front of you you ever go to a
diner or something there's always a
paper somebody read
right and i sit down i give the waitress
to the order i'm sitting and i look over
and i went like this just out of
you know you just go like that to the
middle and when i opened it said
do you want to be a stand-up comic whoa
and there was an article about how
roseanne became a stand-up comic and now
because of denver
she had just blown up like roseanne had
just blown up
it was uh maybe march of 91.
roseanne had just blown up denver was a
hotbed jack everybody was drinking the
water
everybody was wanting to see what
roseanne was doing so it had a big thing
about roseanne
and it had all these open mic spots and
it had classes that you could take and
there was a class in boulder
for 33 dollars three sundays in a row
at the university of colorado part of
the continuing education
the guy that taught it his name was jeff
harms
and i went the first sunday did okay
went the second sunday did okay and the
third sunday i performed
and on the way out he took me inside and
he goes i don't know how serious you are
about this but you're on to something
if you want to do it let me know and i
left that going
i want to sell coke [ __ ] crap
jokes i want to crack
[ __ ] jokes don't do anything i'll be
a pickpocket
magician and [ __ ] come up with birds
and [ __ ]
i swear to god like oh my god you
[ __ ] crazy i want to sell calm
[ __ ] me a comedian and then about a
month later i saw an
ad in the paper for doormen for comedy
clubs
and i called it up and they said come up
and on the way there i called jeff
he gave me his number because he said
you want to go on stage just call me
i'll put you up somewhere
and i go there's a job for a doorman at
wit's end
do you think i can get it he goes i'll
call the guy right now you got it just
drive there and fill out the app and
tell them you're friends with me
and they made me a doorman slash
a sound guy wow and the bar back quit
so i was the door guy sound guy in the
in the bar back and after about six
months i
had two jobs i hated going home i had a
marriage that was just
[ __ ] just like the ones we all talk
about
when you cannot go home it's not your
home anymore right
i would basically leave at six come home
at five take a shower
eat whatever [ __ ] crap she cooked
give the baby a kiss and i'd get in my
truck and go back to westminster
it was a club away from the comedy worse
it was in westminster
but it wasn't it didn't get the best
people in the world you know what i'm
saying like you have toothless people in
there and
people who poach bears and [ __ ] like
that
so i started there and then in the
middle of all that
it took me two months to get a spot from
wendy
and then i went down there and nicole
saw me one of the original owners of the
economy store
wendy with the comedy what's up comedy
world comedy works denver he was one of
the original owners
when he had nickel saw me and told me to
keep coming back
but i knew when i walked off that stage
that life as i knew it has had ended
how so whatever i
thought life was at that point had gone
out the window like i
look saturday was [ __ ] up for me
because saturday i i was supposed to be
somewhere this week but i couldn't go
i had to go to my friend's mother's 80th
birthday party
and why was important it was in philly
it was away from philly she's in an old
folks home because they're the
second family that took me in when my
mom died
like they took me in a crucial spot joe
like you're throwing me out
i'm 17. and i got nowhere to go
i couldn't go to my stepfather so i
had an aunt in new york that i could
live with and i had a godmother in
harlem
and i didn't want to live with both of
them joe like i was
i just mentioned to a friend one day we
were out snorting coke and drinking
and i told them i go where i'm standing
they're throwing me out of their data
and he wasn't even good friends with me
and about a week later i saw him at
school and he goes hey man i talked to
my father you can move in with us
that was whose birthday it was on
saturday you know so
when i got off the phone with her i was
thinking about how important they were
to me
but i still remember being 17 and
sitting on that hill on 86th and county
boulevard
thinking about how i had nowhere to go
bro
like this was my only shot like i had
nowhere to go
like nowhere there wasn't like a
homeless channel i didn't know where the
[ __ ] to go
i probably had ten dollars in my pocket
and then the younger brother ran up the
hill and he goes dog
they're waiting for you to scum to eat
the dinner i'm over there i had never
met the parents
how lucky am i enjoy i never met the
parents that's pretty lucky
and i walked in and they had like six
kids
and it wasn't like what i was used to
living they had no air conditioner
the parents were blue collar and they
took me in they made me a part of their
home
never asked me for rent wasn't the
[ __ ]
best house in the block but till this
day
i'm tight with all the four brothers and
sisters like we're it's like we're all
one big family
but think how [ __ ] lucky like i'm not
even talking about
being thankful for the comedy bridge
just the personal bridge that i went
over
like i was a killer and at that point i
had lost all faith in
uh humanity like i was done
like i wasn't a catholic no more i was
just waiting to kill somebody
that's it that's all i was waiting on
it's such a weird
like i'm not even worried about the
comedy bridge no more it was the
personal brits where i grew the most
you know i don't even know how we got in
this conversation this weed is killing
me
it's good weed they're gonna kill the
good weed now right is that what's
happening
how does this work what how's the new no
no no no i still got some guys
yeah i'm sure you do i mean legally but
legally for it'll still be available for
medicinal
people so we gotta get a card yeah
recreational it's gonna be gotta renew
that card son
i got it i gotta renew that card
i don't want any of your [ __ ] weed i
don't want any of your [ __ ] watered
down weed what are they going to do they
got to water it down
how much 18 something like that but
never fear but here's the thing
isn't that strong uncle joey's here look
at [ __ ] never fear look at this
we got a d.a one two oh wow what do you
think you're dealing with here joey
bananas we got state
federal we got them coming from all over
you know what i'm saying yeah
damn dea [ __ ] yeah just in case you know
just in case just in case
the american man i was looking at the
medicinal rules in ohio recently you
can't grow your own there
if you have a card yeah they're sneaky
with that [ __ ] right yeah
hopefully people eventually vote that
out but you had to get it in there first
that's the only way it would have passed
they have everything wired up
but it's a it's a victory because it's
going to be very difficult to make it
illegal now that it's legal it's going
to be very difficult to go backwards so
then you have to figure out like why do
these companies
have a monopoly on making it if it's
legal
why can't you make it yourself aren't
tomatoes legal i can grow tomatoes can i
you could even probably grow like do you
need a tax stamp or something to grow
tobacco
how does that work maybe to sell it
i'll check like if you wanted to grow
your own tobacco would you be able to do
that like if you said i want to make my
own [ __ ] pipes
and uh you know fill them with my own
tobacco i want to make my own cigars
could you do that
is that possible for personal use that's
crazy so if you could do that
federally and then they're saying you
can't
in ohio you can't grow your own weed
that's that's so stupid that's so dumb
like how do you let that go do you even
know what you're doing
no you're like me i don't know i don't
know dick about it i wouldn't do it
but you should be able to if it's legal
of course you should be able to grow it
that's it's a [ __ ] plan you know
nobody's waiting for them to not grow it
where can you not grow in ohio if you
have a card
here's the worry the worry is that you
wouldn't
charge taxes you would keep the money
you wouldn't be accurate you just do it
with cash you do
cash transactions that's the worry but
that would be a tax worry
more that right is that what it is that
they're saying tobacco too yeah you can
grow as much as you want you just can't
sell it
okay but you they're not even allowed to
grow their own for personal use when it
comes to marijuana so it's more
restrictive than tobacco
which is hilarious silly [ __ ]
that's so dumb does that make any sense
to you
we have some wacky laws that we let
sneak through like why would you let
other people decide
that different people in this group
can't grow a plant
that's legal now get the [ __ ] out of
here that's
dumb that's a dumb rule they can't
somebody go no weed that's loose
anymore so if i come into your store and
i go what do you got you can't open up
the container and show me the button let
me smell it
they all have to be sealed and stuff
there's just a lot of silly rules i
don't know which ones they don't
i'm very happy i found this bag of
expired [ __ ] uh
chiba shoes from 2015
listen you know me i make it work are
they diminished in any way
no no no a couple of them have a little
bit of mold on them you just take the
mold off
i put a little brown nail polish on it
and nobody knows about that did you see
it like it's like nothing who gives a
[ __ ] a little mold never killed nobody
molds help people penn state right yeah
penicillin came from some mold didn't it
something like that it's so crazy how
you see it with your kids
you see it with your kids i took my kid
to science camp
and when i came from cuba i had a lot of
problems uh medically
here when i came to this country and one
of them was the
allergies the allergies were completely
different than when i was using a
different country they're [ __ ]
mind-boggling
so my allergy if you ever hear me make
that noise you ever hear me do that
that's because i don't i can't scratch
the back of my throat like normal people
you know how normal people do that noise
so you all sealed up up there yeah the
first week of camp i saw my daughter do
[ __ ] and i felt so bad for
she would try to scratch her nose and i
would see her get
frustrated joe rogan just scratching and
scratching and scratching
and now it's gone three weeks into
summer camp she don't scratch them how
come
because you build up your [ __ ] immune
system oh
it's so weird how you see it in front of
you now
you see it i see it i saw it in front of
me like i went right to my wife and i go
let me tell you something you better
take it to the [ __ ] doctor
and get the [ __ ] tonsils out because
that's the [ __ ] that started with me at
that age
when i came from cuba right away i was
in the hospital on a weekly level dog
weekly between the tonsils and the
[ __ ] allergies
and the asthma and the asthma
but my mother didn't pay attention to
the asthma that's why i don't have it
today
like i might have bits and pieces of it
but i don't have him
mercy's got it my daughter's got it
they got to do the [ __ ] inhaler in
the whole thing asthma was [ __ ]
roughed
it's rough that's rough i've seen people
have asthma attacks and you see you
could
hear the wheezing and you have no
[ __ ] idea so i have to
work it from a different angle what can
what can they do
like if someone doesn't have an inhaler
and they have an asthma attack
is there a strategy or a technique my
friend's mother died at a [ __ ] party
oh no yeah so you have to be from an
asthma attack
yeah oh like us having a party right now
oh
having a great time i got an asthma
attack
and the inhaler opens up your your lungs
and breathing how it works my wife has
the machine
it's the machine i'm a machine that
blows some powder in it with a thing and
then there's a regular machine that my
wife has and then she has the inhaler
uh you know my wife and her and the
doctor been working on different things
she's healthy i mean the kid's healthy
as [ __ ] she runs she swims
jiu jitsu this that ballet you know
it's it's four days a week we don't stop
at that [ __ ] house
you know you just you see it yeah you
know people i love these people i think
let's meet at 3 30. you tell your mother
to 3 30.
3 30 is when my day really starts you
know i'm saying
i'm writing jokes at eight not because i
want to because that's what i got
yeah that's what i got that's what i got
because i got this that
this that and at three o'clock from
monday to [ __ ] friday
that's a different activity sometimes
you do three at a time bro
we go right from jiu jitsu right to the
pool when she jumps in
you think we could do an hour with jiu
jitsu and then go to a pool and swim for
45 minutes
[ __ ] you jack yeah you got to see it
it's it's unbelievable people like nah
let's meet [ __ ] you i got ballet
i got a thousand [ __ ] activities
during the week kids are a little energy
machines and if you don't burn that
energy then you deal with it
from seven to nine when you're [ __ ]
trying to do your own [ __ ]
and trying to get it together they're
just constantly ready to go
they're ready to go a couple weeks ago
she took it to the [ __ ] zoo
six hour walk around la zoo i get home
at four
he's like what's the story we're going
to the park i looked at my wife like
park
took it to the park two hours on the
monkey bars and then another hour at the
[ __ ] yogurt place jumping up and down
to music and michael jackson and [ __ ]
drawing [ __ ] pictures
really is crazy being a [ __ ] dad
especially because they don't know i
kidnapped somebody like she's
she has no idea she has no idea i'm a
savage
so she thinks i'm on the up and up like
when we go to church and [ __ ] she's like
daddy look at jesus yeah
well nothing turns people more on the up
and up than being a father
it really does yeah it changes who you
are you're responsible for these people
now
and you just do you have to think of
things differently you have to make sure
that you provide
you have to make sure that they're taken
care of you've got to give them love
it's like
it's an intense world and you feel more
vulnerable and it's just
the whole the world around you opens up
and you also have more empathy i have
way more empathy for people
now because i i'm becoming you know as
you're
raising children you're seeing how they
develop
and then you're considering how other
people
have been mistreated and how things have
gone terribly wrong they've been abused
and beaten
and [ __ ] up and left in terrible
situations and
you realize that so much of
what happens with people with even
terrible behavior
comes from other terrible behavior like
they didn't get a chance to stop the
cycle
and they're a lot of people that we
consider like really bad people
violent people people that do terrible
things they we don't even realize that
so many of them are a product of
violence
like they're a product of someone doing
it to them like they've
almost they're trying to get back at the
world for all the horrible [ __ ] that's
been done to them
and there was no one there to put a stop
to it there was no one there to save
them
there was no one there to protect them
and
this is what we're seeing when we see
[ __ ] up people we
always just think of it as [ __ ] up
people but that
[ __ ] up person is the product of some
terrible things that have happened to
them almost universally
almost every angry [ __ ] up person has
come from a place where something has
gone
really wrong against them you don't
you're not angry and [ __ ] up if
everything's awesome
if every day just getting ice cream
getting your dick sucked and driving a
ferrari and
watching awesome movies like you know
it's you
there's a there's an anger that some
people have violent criminals
in particular that comes from someone
doing that to them
i had the language i know you did i had
that anger from
you had that [ __ ] when i met you i had
that anger but no
you had that when i met you i've seen it
i've seen it with people well let me
explain something
wanted to attack people the anger was
very
uh all right first of all under control
i was always a happy kid
and uh but not really because i was
always confused about the death of my
father
hmm so that always had a little certain
unhappiness yeah
but i always had the catholic faith i
was really raised catholic
and i always believed he was in heaven
and he was in that box when my mom did
the things
so i lose the pain a little bit then my
mother's death
was just [ __ ] horrifying and that
broke
the central nervous system belief system
that broke your belief in the world
how can there be a god that takes a
mother away from a child
when you're 16 and you wrap that around
your head
there's not a good result it's not going
to be a good result
so how i lashed out was by robbing you
that was the only weapon i had in the
world was to rob you
joe rogan [ __ ] me this studio would
get robbed and lit on
[ __ ] fire and joe knew it was me and
what the [ __ ] was he gonna do i'm with
carmine
what the [ __ ] you gonna do you call the
cops it's karma they're gonna answer the
phone
next time don't [ __ ] with me you'll know
next time not to [ __ ] with me when i
tell you to give me that gram of coke
and i'll pay you on friday you'll
[ __ ] give it to me all right
because that's what it was it was simple
[ __ ] like that right like joe give me a
hundred bucks
bro joey i don't have 900 bucks okay
then i robbed your [ __ ] house you
should have given me
100 bucks you know i was lashing out at
the [ __ ] world right
number two the other issue i had is i
lost a child
i lost a child i was not ready for that
child
at all i loved that little girl with all
my heart but i was not ready for her
at all my intentions were good but the
result was not gonna be well i was not
ready
and because i lost that child and i'm in
no contact with that child
it makes me the better father that i am
today this is never going to happen to
me again
do you understand me yeah i see
i see the we see daughters of comics
we've seen daughters of comics and sons
of comics
and they're [ __ ] lost you know
i don't want my daughter to be [ __ ]
lost
in that stupidity in that world you know
you have to be there joe we have to be
there yeah you know
you have to be there i'm trying to be
there as much as i can
you have to be engaged you know you have
to be engaged will your parents engage
as much as you're engaged not mine but i
didn't want a different
world yes it's a different world but my
parents were very open-minded
what my parents gave to me that was
really important was they they're like
the most
non-judgmental non-racist
non-homophobic people ever they don't
judge about
anything they were hippies you know when
when my mom met my stepdad he had crazy
long hair and he had it like
all all till i was like almost in high
school was when he cut i was so happy
when he cut it i was like
people were like back then dudes grew
their hair long
they were hippies like legit hippies but
because of that
i was raised around like no racism
no homophobic we had uh no homophobic
thoughts in our house we
that never came up we lived in san
francisco from the time i was
seven till i was 11. we lived all in a
serious gate and one thing that did
disturb me though once
i was walking with my stepdad some dude
whistled at him
some dude was like
i knew that dudes were gay but there's a
thing about
when a dude is hitting on your straight
stepdad and you're like
oh my goodness this is ridiculous like
guys are gross
it makes you realize it doesn't even
really make you realize what it would
like to be a chick in that same exact
same i grew up
completely different not in my home
not in my home but the surroundings
you know when i would walk down the
corner mr tina would go spicaroo where
you going tonight
you know jesus guys there was a kid that
i still talked to him on
facebook his name is louis hernandez
he's dominican
joe he's dominican he's dominican they
didn't give a [ __ ] they called him louis
the [ __ ]
constantly louis the [ __ ] the guys
he's dominican
do you think they gave a [ __ ] they
didn't give a [ __ ] they didn't give a
[ __ ] so
funny you know they didn't give a [ __ ]
uh people
were just different then it's a
different world we're talking about
right
i remember there was a kid that is today
gay i still talk to him he's my brother
as a matter of fact he's one of my
brothers i got to be honest with you
he lives in miami he's got hiv i mean
listen if you didn't know he was gay
when he was 12
there's something wrong with you but
mrtino used to call him
he was lighting the slippers you know
look at look at jimmy he's lighting the
slippers
you know and you had to sit there and
take it it was
uh whatever it should be okay
for a little jimmy lighting the slippers
everybody should just let him be
he was my best friend he had a dog named
[ __ ] that was the dirtiest dog
ever like he lived outside [ __ ] skin
like when your pet the [ __ ] thing was
that hardest it was like uh
like with those brushes you scrub like a
metal brush
like he lived outside [ __ ] but he
followed him everywhere he was beautiful
i love [ __ ]
dogs no you're very lucky because i
they're the best they're the best pets
you know i grew up in an environment i'm
standing with you and
my man here we're on the corner we see a
transgender person crossing the street
you're like look at the shape of this
[ __ ] guy
as simple as that is that's a judgment
that's a judgment but it was more of a
sense of humor
you know before we were looking at a
picture of uh of uh
archie bunker america understood it
because he
they knew where he was coming from he
wasn't saying nothing malicious
it was a world where he came from right
and the idea was that he
was reluctantly open to occasionally
taking new information
in america today every guy is sitting at
home [ __ ] looking out the window
peeking
waiting to [ __ ] to get me toot
there's a thousand men at home
waiting right now to get me [ __ ] dude
every day a new guy gets [ __ ] called
out for something like that
what's this gonna be like in five years
nobody's gonna be able to even ask for a
[ __ ] piece
[Music]
nobody's gonna go hey let me give you a
little stab let me give you a little
bacaloosh
i think there's going to come a time
and then and i don't think it's going to
be very long within 10 years
where we're going to be able to read
each other's minds i think we're going
to be able to communicate
in a different way and i think it's just
going to be step one
into some sort of a technological world
where we all read each other's minds
we can connect together in some almost
like telepathic web way
the way you use uh this is obviously
just an idea
but i think that if technology
continues to give us closer and closer
access to people we're going to lose all
boundaries between what a person is and
you're going to know everything about
everyone's past
and everyone's going to know everything
about yours and it's going to be like
some
unlimited library of the mind you can
you can travel through anyone's mind and
read anyone's thoughts and as
100 years goes by and the technology
gets better and a thousand years go by
we're going to integrate we're going to
figure out a way whether it's in
our grandchildren's lifetimes or their
grandchildren's lifetimes
and i think that cultural shifts
and things that are happening in the
news and people waking up to things that
they think are horrible
and people trying to correct the the
misdeeds of the past
all of that is us waking up in the
middle of our culture
and trying to figure out what's right
figure out what's the the healthy way to
move forward figure balance this thing
out
slow down what are we doing we're waking
up as grown adults trying to figure out
our system
and there's some injustices those
injustices have to be corrected
or at least recognized we have to
understand what's the difference
between normal male female
interaction and what's sexual harassment
what when is it when someone doesn't
want you to do it
when does it become a crime you know
when you don't want your daughter to
ever experience that and i don't want
anybody that's a woman to experience
real sexual harassment
it's the worst [ __ ] thing that could
probably ever happen to you because you
can't do anything physically about it
other than rape or being beaten up or
murdered it's a creepy
place to be in i've had guys hit on me
before you ever heard a guy hit on you
before were you like
hey where is this going i was like 13.
yeah i grabbed my dick i didn't know
what to do i ran out of the car and it
was my fault for getting in the [ __ ]
car
i also acknowledged it and it never
[ __ ] happened again
and i would go to gate theaters when i
was a kid like we thought it was a joke
to go to a [ __ ] porn
theater on a sunday you go to a porno on
a sunday like with six of your stupid
friends and go to the bathroom
and there's always a guy that gets next
to you in the store when you go pee and
he looks at your dick and he smiles
come on guys yeah i've bumped into a lot
of creep you've been out here first of
all
i tell you what bothers me about the
current situation how it went off
that this [ __ ] place here has always
been a [ __ ] haven for sexual
harassment
this [ __ ] neighborhood down the
corner here hollywood is where sexual
harassment got invested invented
did you ever see um all the stuff about
fatty arbuckle
i heard pieces about fatty arbor but i
don't need to know about fatty
i know about a chick named marilyn
monroe that they passed around until
they killed her
i know about a guy named liberace who
used to suck your dick and [ __ ] clean
you out and then send you out
into the [ __ ] cold and worse he would
you know get plastic surgery so he
looked like like you look like him
look the doctor is one of the most
intense things a person's ever made a
person do and let me tell you something
and let me tell you something else too
let's while we're [ __ ] the elephants
in the room the [ __ ] where we hang
out
was known for a comedy [ __ ] hell of
den of sucking dick too for a lot of
years at the comedy store
a lot of dick sucker went down to
[ __ ] comedy store i don't know how
long harvey weinstein's been around
but there's a song by the eagles in 1980
that was released on the [ __ ] long
run their last album
and it's called the king of hollywood on
the way home put it on listen to it in
the car
you're gonna crash your car call the
king of [ __ ] hollywood and he you're
gonna go who the [ __ ]
were they talking about i have to i mean
it just breaks it down
it would be a shame to see all that
talent go to waste
you know what are you willing to
sacrifice wouldn't you really be just
nice
oh you got look at this [ __ ] come sit
down here beside me honey
let's have a little heart to heart
that's the [ __ ] lyrics to this song
wow king of hollywood 1980 nobody knew
now look at me and tell me darling how
badly do you want this part
yeah let's listen you put men in
positions of power
and hiring women like that in that that
crazy position of
what you're trying to cast something and
you got a hundred people that want it so
bad and you're
you know you're some creepy dude some
people actually think that this would
change
their life if i came to you right now
and said joe rogan you're [ __ ]
delivering papers in boston
you're gonna have two shows you're gonna
have a podcast all you gotta do is lick
my [ __ ] ball
oh my goodness just swallow it one time
but i want you to do i want
how much do i get in how long do i have
to suck them for because like
it's going to be over pretty quick this
is a [ __ ] career changer
if clark gable may do just do that right
that's who they were talking about oh
the king of hollywood
yeah is was clark gable a um
was he a gay man it was based off of a
book
apparently all this stuff that was in
there
but he was he alleged to be a gay man
was this no idea
no this is nothing like this but there
was also a book released in hollywood
in 1997 or eight called you'll never
work in this town again oh so those
lyrics were about clark gable
yeah oh i'm sorry i thought it was yeah
yeah yeah yeah but then there was a book
released in 1997 or eight
in this hollywood called you'll never
work in this town again
and it was about a chick who described
all her sexual relationships with a
bunch of people in town
and she described [ __ ] don henley the
drummer from the eagles the guy that
sings
and he would get hookers to come up to
the house
wouldn't even talk to them well line
them up
turn around don't even look at me don't
even make [ __ ] eye contact with me
you understand me
bend over so he would sit on the couch
with a robe on with his deck out snort
and coke and they would all be
in front of a fireplace bent over
where'd you hear this this is in his
book
you'll never work in this town again
jesus christ
and he would [ __ ] it you never eat lynch
in this town again
oh you never eat lunch and he would take
the thing do a line of coke
get up and walk up to one of them
spread them putting them in their ass a
little bit of that [ __ ]
pump it twice and then you know i'll be
back in five minutes and then he would
go sit down
put his feet up do another line and he
would do that for eight hours
just get up [ __ ] one for five minutes
and sit back down before he'd come
so he would never crack a nut and he
would just keep snorting to keep her
heart on alive
[ __ ] fist so who the [ __ ] knows
listen you know it's like they all threw
the
harvey under the bus but these animals
had been doing this
since jesus loves chicago since jesus
chicago listen when i read that article
about the cuban superman that they
brandon was sleeping with what they
blatantly talked about in that article
was exactly what we're seeing today only
behind closed doors that cuba had become
a haven for sex
where you could go see a [ __ ] goat
get [ __ ] i mean didn't they pass a
rule this week in mexico
that a girl could get [ __ ] if she's 12
years old
you really need that rule really that's
the rule you need is that really what
just got passed
something that you could beat that eight
12 years old is the
act of and this is in mexico in mexico
why is a woman 12 years old that's
insane that's insane
it's scary it is real
talk you [ __ ] believe that oh my god
look at this
the federal law established at the age
of 12 as the minimum age of consent
while the age at which there are no
restrictions for consensual sexual
activities is 18.
sex with someone 12 to 18 is not illegal
per se
but can still be open to prosecution
under certain circumstances
what does that mean so it's it's age
12 is the age of minimum age of consent
but the age in which there are no
restrictions for consensual sex is 18.
so the idea is that sex between someone
who's 12 and 18
it's not illegal but they might be able
to lock you up if you do something super
creepy
that is nuts man you imagine if there's
like some
person that just only went after 12
years now where is that that's
from the united states or mexico it's
mexico so that's why people would fly
down there is it actually
i typed in mexico but this is an article
on wikipedia about agent consent north
america
laws i'll find out wait a minute that
what i just read was about north america
how is that real i just saw north
america too and that's why i asked them
there's states where i i'm sorry not in
north america united states of america
right north america is canada too
that is that is a that is a not possible
thing how is it
is that really possible that 12 could be
the age of consent anywhere
oh no yeah what are you talking about
that's crazy 18 right that's the federal
law of mexico
mexico yeah you scared the [ __ ] out of
me jamie no it the
kid [ __ ] here in america it's no yeah
yes this
article is about north america age of
consent in north america
and there is states here where it's
lower than
18. what yeah like there's a couple i
believe it's 14.
dude is that real it might have changed
it really okay so
12 17. the 12 are the ones that are in
white
which is that's in mexico right down
here yeah okay there are spots
and all the way up the coast right
yep that's still mexico down here yeah
that side but
that that whole thing is 12 years old
the age of consent the blue is all 16.
whoo that's a lot of states at 16. yeah
that's kind of crazy
it's just a lot of [ __ ] us states how
cool it's 16.
that's crazy 14 18 and central excuse me
what does it say central america oh 14
to 18 in central america interesting
that's uh that age of consent thing is
bananas go back to that little map again
please
that is weird to look at i would have
thought there would be
way less of those 16 look how many 16s
there are
and what are the darker ones can you
scroll all the way down so we can see
the whole scale
so 17 is that and then
wow taxes are seven green is 18.
so it's only like florida california
there's less greens and there are blues
more the age of consent is 16. is this
current is that possible this is
not current it seems
nuts alaska's 16-2
i assumed it was all 18. i thought
florida was like eight
you know florida could be like seven six
and a half
you never know that i'm [ __ ] that
crazy place that is a
[ __ ] crazy place that's where white
people go to boogie
didn't have like paint i i i just found
out about that
there was a time you go down and just
buy pills over the [ __ ] counter or
something
go pain doctors pain medications yeah
like i just read this [ __ ] recently that
that law got abolished or something
that's why so many people left florida
there were people moving to florida in
droves just for those pain doctors
and droves i didn't know about this [ __ ]
yeah
well there's a great documentary that
we've talked about many times called the
oxycontin express
and they sort of uh documented that
whole
route from ohio and kentucky
and all the way down through georgia all
the people that would go into florida
just to get pain pills all you had to do
is just get into florida
and you'd get a doctor and say you hurt
your back and they would have a pharmacy
right next to the doctor's office and
all the pharmacy had is pain pills
so you go there you tell the doctor
you're hurt the doctor says great here
here's some [ __ ]
serious hardcore drugs that can kill you
don't take more of these
you'll die they're super powerful
opiates but since i wrote the
wrote it on this piece of paper you can
go buy it so you go next door and you're
buying
you're buying the hardest of hardcore
you're buying
hillbilly heroin you're buying oxycontin
you're going deep
now i've never done that [ __ ] i did
morphine when i got my knee operated on
they gave me that little pump thing and
you could press it and press it and
press it and you want to get more
morphine
i don't i have no idea what oxycontin
feels like but that morphine felt
wonderful it feels like cotton did not
feel good what does it feel like
i ate it one time and that was good
enough for me
some people must like it all right
everybody likes different [ __ ] you know
i like blow but i don't like meth
what did oxy do for you like why is it
not good i took
a little tiny piece like i'm always a
fan of something that might put me to
sleep
i don't feel like this could put you to
sleep you know what i'll give it a
[ __ ] shot
i like sleeping you try to go to sleep
on oxycontin
yeah i didn't know i go what he goes you
you might pass up
so he gave me a 16th it was there was
nothing there
right there was nothing there i popped
it
and i just felt like my blood pressure
dropped like i couldn't even do anything
so i went to sleep and i just knew
never to take that [ __ ] again there's
certain [ __ ] i've taken that
i just knew that i was never gonna that
just wasn't gonna work for me
damn you know heroin has that effect too
for a little while like it takes you
somewhere
and if you don't put the brakes on and
[ __ ] then you're gone on that thing
i don't even know how to describe it but
i don't like that feeling
you know the cocaine feeling you like in
the beginning
then where it goes you don't like it and
then it gets worse and worse and worse
but by that time you're addicted to it
you know what i'm saying matt i never
understood that [ __ ]
i wanted to be up for four days that
that just seems
and you will be up for two [ __ ] days
thinking you're tired like let me go lay
down
and i'll say like i can't sleep i'm
sweating awesome i got a dose of sweat
so pills i've always had that i i like a
little [ __ ] sleeping pill or
something but i can't because of this
uh sleep yeah they're too dangerous
right
i could take the anxiety medication
that'll help me sometimes i'll pop a few
of those what if i get stuck
they're like acid pan but they're like
1.5 dogs don't do nothing to nobody
0.5 lets you go to sleep
weed at night don't do dick you ever see
me at night smoking weed not really
because the initial effect was in the
daytime that's what you like
i like that morning high why do you like
that oh
because that's the one that gets the
whole that's the one that lets me email
text tweet ding ding da da da da da
all by nine o'clock um all by nine
o'clock
get it out of the way yeah so if i'm up
at quarter six
put the coffee on open up the computer
feed the cats
i don't pablo it see there's people who
pablo it that's no bueno escobar
yeah what's that pablo it open your eyes
in bed
roll over and take a joint and smoke it
that's no bueno you gotta let your body
wake up that's no bueno that's the
quickest way what's that [ __ ]
thing yeah let me take a hit of that you
know i love that little blunt that
[ __ ] geno from speedweed you're some
of the best [ __ ]
jamie picked this one up this is a
different one this is a gino
the uh what's it tell you what hollywood
blunts or something i don't know
hollywood hollywood's
dedicated blunt you're waking up and
pulling the pablo
people everyone should be yeah it's
medicine man
okay but if you wake up and give your
body some chance to like i remember
smoking cigarettes in the morning
you don't know what what damage
is to your body
until you wake up in the morning take
six steps
sit down and pull a cigarette out and
light it there is no worse damage
a human being can do that body forget
heroin forget eating a few avocados
forget eating a burger king whopper
[Music]
get up at six in the morning give
yourself three minutes and light a
cigarette
your body does not recover from that and
you don't know how bad it is to you stop
doing
it that's damage
so i look at it the same day away with
reef i let my body wake up a little bit
let it air
drink water let the bodies heat drink a
glass of water with ice
let my body's heat wake up get the
stomach going
drink a little coffee and then bang out
some reefer
ooh lordy it's a different day
and you like to work out in the morning
too right i'm 55.
i can't come to your house eight o'clock
at night but i can't i'm not gonna roll
with you at six in the morning either
most heart attacks happen before one
time do they yeah how come
i don't know i didn't write the book
check it out most heart attacks happen
before [ __ ] 12 o'clock
so you don't want to be yeah i know you
don't want joey diaz on in your side
control
at six in the morning either i'm good at
nine
to kick box 10 the kick box 11 12 the
jiu jitsu eyes
yeah you got to wake everything up
that's the whole deal heart attacks are
more common in the morning says fox news
five to six times more likely to occur
in the morning hours between
1 and 5 a.m and studies have shown that
morning heart attacks tend to be more
severe
than those that happen later in the day
too long or too short of an interval can
result in abnormal heart rhythms
called arrhythmias as a matter of fact i
had to stop getting mama stabbing in the
mornings
you were worried about heart attacks
yeah cause that was my more i love
morning eating [ __ ] in the morning just
wake him up whoa what is all this
when you kick mama with that leg in the
morning you know what i'm saying you
ever give your little wife a tap in the
morning she pops her head up
and then they they already know they get
up they pee they dry the monkey good
they come back naked you eat that
[ __ ] monkey
and then you start giving them a stab
him like a soldier and that stabbing
dog i would have to get up and start
breathing heavy
and then i thought about that that
[ __ ] gangster that was going to
testify that time in court
and he bent over to pattaya's shoes and
they had a heart attack
and the guy ended up doing a [ __ ] in
jail and we got to talk about that too
in a second but we
will cover the heart attack i take a
baby aspen before i go
i drink something from gnc to get me
going a little bit in the mornings i
still take my honey protein powder i
live by
but i do take a supplement before i go
to the gym and i do drink something
while i'm at the gym to calm me down a
little bit
what do you drink something from gnc i
like gnc
i don't know names hmm you don't know
names i don't know names
i just know performance levels i always
pop a shroom tech again i don't pop two
shroom texts i pop one
and i started with a half a capsule
because i was finding my heart was
beating too much you gotta watch the
ticker yeah you gotta watch the ticker
that's interesting you know listen god
gives you a certain amount of ticks to
your heart
i did coke that that that [ __ ] up the
whole clock that
that that [ __ ] up the speedometer you
got sand in your dial yeah i got sand in
the dials like i [ __ ] up the
speedometer so now i gotta strengthen it
a little bit
and that's what strengthens it but
there's a lot of [ __ ] you could do
without thinking like a marathon or
something
yeah i watch my fingers no numbness i go
i get a finger up my ass as much as i
could from the doctor
i use i overuse insurance dollars
like i'm going friday for a blood test
why joey because i'm in the mud
you got to switch out the blood every
couple months you know what i'm saying
you got to switch it out like keith
richards he's still alive because he
switched it out look at women don't die
a heart attacks why because they bleed
every month
what do you only i was like don't take
the what's the matter with you today
you're like a [ __ ] what
i'm just you just with you buddy okay
relax
you don't want to be no i'm enjoying
your conversation i don't know
you're just smoking so much weed you're
getting paranoid no i love it you've
taken
five hits off that thing you just been
just sucking it down and getting
deeper and deeper into the hole you're
like what's the matter
it's not nothing's the matter at all
it's the fourth it's i'm like suck
is this [ __ ] great to see you look
beautiful too what's going on with you
normal [ __ ] you know just doing workouts
last night no i'm coming tonight you're
going down there tonight yeah i got a
spot tonight
i don't know if i'm going down i've been
taking a few days off after the netflix
yeah nice i wanted to fall in love again
with it
i wanted to uh it's good to take time
off things it's really weird how
you live and you learn and you still
fall for dumb [ __ ]
you know the only person i should listen
to when it comes to comedy is you
and i don't see you enough and i don't
talk to you enough about it i got to get
on more planes with you
because when i tried i watched the john
mulaney special and i fell in love with
his joke writing and stuff
he's a very funny guy really nice guy
too really nice guy
[ __ ] great [ __ ] special you know
but every once in a while i'm sorry i'm
saying this word i always think i get
the white moment and i'm not a white
comic
the reason why you like me and the
people like me is because you don't know
what's going to come out of my mouth
when i become a writer
that's when i'm not a comedian no more
when i go home and start writing stupid
[ __ ] jokes and you laugh at him
i'm not joey diaz no more that's not
what joey diaz is supposed to do
you know what i'm saying no that's not
what i'm supposed to do yeah but this
[ __ ] that's happening now scares the
[ __ ] out of me
so now i got to go up there you paid 25
bucks to see me i got to go up and
leave my soul up there i take that [ __ ]
seriously now but i'm starting to take
it a little bit too seriously the [ __ ]
you see now
in what way the the people coming to the
shows
people coming to the shows to see you
and they want to do you
to see you do well so i go up there with
this planned material
that i work on hard that i believe in
that's [ __ ]
because i'm a lot friendlier when i go
up there and i just [ __ ] yell and
scream and go off the cuff and go crazy
and my eyeballs turn red
but no i want to be john [ __ ] the
mullaney because he makes me [ __ ]
laugh and he's
what in your mind the true comic is yeah
everybody's got their own way of doing
it
no and that's what i realized i'm going
back to being a [ __ ] lunatic i'm
going back to midnight spots
next week i'm going back to midnight
spots i'm going back to cali
cali cali going back to cali yo i'm
going back to those paul mooney spots
i know they're late but they're the only
ones that keep you if you're gonna play
it if you listen
for me to be in uniform is the only way
i could do it that 1015
following you that ain't fun no more we
got to be back there late like we used
to
and go on four hours of sleep for two or
three weeks
then you got to walk me over and buy me
a [ __ ] pink dot sandwich like in the
old days why don't you like the 10 15
spots let's put
because they put me in that position i'm
sick of [ __ ] being in that [ __ ]
john mulaney position i'm not john
mulaney
tonight but like you're there to see me
because
something's going to come out of my
mouth that's going to be funny there's
nothing funny coming out of my [ __ ]
mouth
listen i love you but you're that's
this is crazy talk you what you do is
your way of doing it it's great at ten
it's great at eight you could do it
three in the afternoon show it would be
amazing they stare at me at the store
sometimes they stare at me in the
original room i'm going back to midnight
no
they don't i'm taking the kennison spots
again three nights a week
because i can handle it that means i get
home at one i'll stay up to 132.
you gonna do the late spots yeah you
know why man the reason why i do this
early [ __ ] is because i'm trying to be
normal i read that book
your podcast like i said okay now i like
this hold on a second so you're gonna
close out the store
and do like an hour-long set no no 15
12 to 12 15. oh so you're not gonna do
like the don
situation no no no no no no no no no no
no listen
joey does the least for the most [ __ ]
up
all right i'm just you saying but you
can if you're closing out the show right
you could go along
i don't want to close out the show one
of the more i don't want to be out i'm
scared of going out at night
so it's not i thought you were saying
you want to do the kinnison spot
that's the case midnight right the
midnight spot when he would do that
oh i thought he was always the last guy
i didn't i thought was the i mean that's
what they always say about brody when he
does the kennison spot and
i don't know i thought it was the
midnight spot let's call it the paul
mooney spot
okay well just you want to do a late
night spot
yeah yeah i think that i would do a lot
better i don't have to go to
more degenerates will be out for sure
yeah yeah
it's ready for me to it's time for me to
be i'm a [ __ ] degenerate i should say
that
fellow degeneres yeah i'm a [ __ ] jedi
in the morning
nobody's saying one did i say one i said
12. okay
[ __ ] one in the morning 12. 12
o'clock you know you're getting up at
one though
let's be realistic no 12 10. yeah you
might
have to start professionals at the store
they're pretty professional they're
professionals there's no more [ __ ]
people coming in and bumping you
well that still happens a little bit but
not too much it's not too much
they don't they don't no one jumps on
and does an hour and a half like the old
days
i miss i miss that 12 o'clock thought of
mind the thought process at 12 for me in
the old days was
i swear to god joe they've already heard
everything
yeah if they if i think
they really want to hear these dumb
three jokes in my pocket
i got another thing coming and it taught
me how to write
really good what do you what has changed
recently like the one of the things a
lot of people have been saying with uh
especially the metoo movement is that
people are more cautious
about saying controversial jokes now
do you feel that you feel like energy in
the air being different
do you feel like people are more
sensitive i know you won't get mad at me
i feel the energy is different but guess
what g what it don't apply to me
it don't apply to me doesn't apply to me
and it's never gonna apply to me
okay i understand me shooting you
special on your network you don't want
me to use certain words there's parts
and i and i get that this is a business
right this is a business
and i got miles to feed but when i'm at
the comedy store
when i'm at the improv when i'm at the
laugh factory when i'm in flappers when
i'm at the haha
when i'm at the new york gotham you got
to let it fly
i'm going to let it fly you got to let
it fly okay and i'm sorry
no no just so you know no sorry you know
this is just so you know you know what i
put on yesterday what did you put on
guess what i put on the studio yesterday
and this is it this is it because it's
time
we're not taking it no more i'm not
taking it no more
i put on an album and again i'm very
sorry if i offend somebody
i didn't name it this he did so take
your [ __ ] problem up with him
name of the album is bicentennial [ __ ]
by james uh richard richard pryor i put
it on
i listened to it twice and i did an
edible and cried
i got the [ __ ] i've got the
the periscope listening to richard
okay i got it yeah okay and
i've listened to lenny bruce live from
carnegie hall in the last couple weeks
i don't know when the last time you
listen tonight because we can't because
of our
uh we guys like you and i can't
definitely not jamie and definitely be
under 30 you can't
because of the uh culture
this is how slow cultural reference is
how slow it is
but it's a lesson i listened to that and
i'm
going home guess what i'm listening to
tonight what i'm staying in tonight to
listen to
the one when he meets the wino meets
dracula oh i think
is it something i said or the nigga's
crazy
both of those albums are masterpieces
and that's
how he wanted us to do it yeah that was
how we have to do it
yeah he didn't give a [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
was said
no if a company wants to pay you hbo
or cbs and i joey can we talk to you in
the corner
we can't have that joke because we got a
complaint about that
i'm an adult i can't sell you know
listen
uh bill hicks is dead i don't feel too
good myself okay
all right let's cut the [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay we do this for profit
at the end of the [ __ ] day we're
feeding our families all right so
but there's also a way you do it and
there's always no way i compromise the
way you do it for more profit
you know when i watch the richard pryor
thing and i know he went through a
hollywood ball and they were doing the
thing for gays and he went up there and
went against the gays i got it
is it something i would do i don't know
i don't know
but it's who was supposed to be in a way
as a comedian
what's supposed to be the social column
of society in a way in some way so now
you want to take that away from me
you want to take the way i can't say i
grew up on the word [ __ ]
i grew up on the word [ __ ] i grew up
on the word i grew up on a lot of words
that people don't accept today
and i'm very sorry that you don't accept
them
but it's too late for me to change my
game right now
yeah i'll try my hardest i try my
hardest
i'm still gonna say [ __ ] from time to
time i know it offends
but when you're a comic listen man the
first
seven minutes of any news is about
what's going on in the world
and the next 10 minutes is bad i never
talk about politics well to top it off
i'm a felon
so i need to talk about politics there's
just things i'm not going to talk about
kicking an abortion
child remember for a long time every
comic was
you know all kicking aboard and feeding
him that's not my style
i'm up there to talk about what are you
talking about you know yeah yeah
you go to comedy shows and there's
always that one that wants to be
shocking
i'm not here to be shocked i'm here to
tell you how i see it you want to hear
how
i see it this is how i see it if i
offend you
i offend you before in the beginning of
the show i said something very offensive
in today's terms
but in my reality it was real you want
firecrackers
you're buying from a chinese dude down
in china why is that racist
because that's racist how is it racist
it's factual chinese people out of
fireworks right there's weird
there's weird ones that we all let fly
like black dudes with big dicks no one's
complaining about that right
you ever hear that you assume black dude
has a big deck does anybody complains
probably they're looking to now that
might be like maybe i'm the first one to
get called out on it
that's racist to think that black dudes
have big dicks
is it if it's positive is it pot is like
a positive
attribute racist like if you said asian
people are better at math people
would say that's racist how is it racist
if they're really good at something
like if they have more talent or skill
or more accomplishments how's that
racist
like that's isn't that racial if it's
good
right like jews accept it if you tell
ari
that more european jews won nobel
science prizes
he's like of course we're smarter is it
is it racist
to talk about how many jews are so
[ __ ] smart like why is that why are
they so goddamn smart
you think about how many german and and
european jews
were like [ __ ] serious geniuses it's
it's a crazy trend
like what happened over there callum was
trying to explain it to me once about
their values their education and
experiences and what led to just
google the numbers of european jews that
have won nobel science prizes it's kind
of like
it's eye-opening you know how many
guineas from new jersey zero
zero guineas from new jersey went in
science right none of my relatives went
in science projects looking this up a
couple weeks ago
it was hard to look at oh is it yeah
what did european jews
that have won the nobel science prize
try that
i don't know i don't even know what this
number is i'm talking on my ass
i know that it's i've definitely heard
it discussed
that there was a giant number what are
you doing over there joey dennis
make sure my wife doesn't text me and
let me know what party i need to be at
oh fourth of july baby this is our
our country's birthday is a time that we
should cherish
i think uh we should play the national
anthem maybe later we got time okay
well we got to play the national anthem
real quick i had on this morning about
my house i loved it i [ __ ] love it so
how was your experience doing your
netflix special
everything was great netflix i take my
hats off to them everything was great it
was
my [ __ ] up it was my [ __ ] up i let it uh
get into my head too much i listened to
too many people and i forgot the number
one thing
just be funny that's it be yourself
it doesn't matter how many shows did you
film two
first one i think was a disaster the
second one i redeemed myself a little
bit we'll put something together and
we'll save something
so now i'm working really hard like now
now i'm going back to my old roots how i
want to do my stand up again
it's hard when you even only have two
shows even only two shows is tough
more [ __ ] yeah no more no more i
listen this has nothing to do with me
i'm a stand-up comic
that's what i signed up for hmm
what do i got left i'm 55 well i got
left to doing stand up another 10 years
maybe
i got to stop now you're going to shut
me down now
no this is where we get started
that's where we get started we got to we
got daughters
when do you think about do you think
about ever stopping doing stand up
because i do occasionally
i think about it and then i take a
flight back with dice from new york and
i look at dice
before i approach him i sit there and i
look at him
from 10 feet away for 10 minutes and i
think to myself is this what i want to
be doing at that age
and i think about what what would we be
doing
what would we be doing you really want
to be around your wife and your
daughters
every [ __ ] weekend for every [ __ ]
week you're already used to leaving one
weekend at least a month
you're already used to it there's going
to be a casino
somebody's gonna pay you once a month to
leave the house for two days but if you
would you be happy with your act if
you're only going out once a month
like if you weren't going up and
practicing going out once a month could
be awful
but don't understand this i'm saying
you're still hosting the pizza place on
wednesday nights
what and you're still let's pretend you
moved to [ __ ] columbus ohio
okay okay move to columbus ohio
and you work the funny bone once a year
right and you do your little pizza open
mic somewhere down the corner a couple
nights a week
they look he was the older guy they all
came up looking the comedy watching you
you know they listen to you you know
when i started economy i started the
guy's name was george mckelvey
and george mckelvey was a really special
guy joe joe because he had been on the
tonight show with
with uh whatever as a comic as a
stand-up
and that's the [ __ ] epitome for one
of us whether he became
uh richard pryor or not he was on what's
his name
come on [ __ ] help me i have no idea
tonight's show johnny carson johnny
carson
he did stand up and johnny put him on
the couch you know took the real i mean
george mckelvey was the real deal
when george was 70. i'll never forget he
called me one night he's like hey what
are you doing a kid like i'm sitting he
goes drive to colorado springs
and get on stage open up me i go i can't
get on that stage
because the famous manager that was at
that
that club at the time mm-hmm wouldn't
let you get on stage unless you took
that comedy class for 35 bucks
oh that was a scam [ __ ] uh i'll wave it
so he threw me on stage and this old guy
liked me
that old guy had no career basically he
did the local places he owned two clubs
and he worked a couple clubs that hired
him still
he died on the road or whatever my point
being that
he helped me a lot as an old guy like i
looked at him
and at first my first opinion of him was
look at this old loser no he wasn't an
old loser
he hadn't been doing it for 30 years he
committed to this and no matter what his
turnout was or whatever he was still a
comic he died a comic
i talked to him like maybe two years
until he died and i lost contact with
him well george carlin died on the road
yeah you know one of the greatest of all
time i don't want to die on the road and
i i know you don't want to die on the
road no
but i can't for years i thought i
wouldn't be doing this at 50.
guess what i'm 55. and i'm still you're
not just doing it this is what's
important you're still letting it swing
you're still having fun and doing a lot
of crazy [ __ ] that gets you in a lot of
trouble today this is what i brought up
with
we were talking about the you know air
quotes me too era
people are going after people today for
good or for bad
and to to still have a wild
controversial act
in this politically what do you want
hold on one second what are we going
after me two people for
for me taking in the back grabbing your
titties grabbing your [ __ ] or
you sucking my dick for a movie role or
for something like that all those things
really don't exist in my life
right i have a wife and i have a child
they don't exist
if you want to come at me for sucking my
dick at night in 2002
we were both both doing blow go ahead be
my guest
be my guest but i want to see footage i
can't be
i'm see i'm sorry and take it and just
you know i'm saying yeah there's a lot
of people out there they're going to get
me too look at this other guy
for years he was known as a heroin
addict never got exclusive
of sexual misconduct and some chick said
she molested it when he was 11 years old
and now he's like you need that you need
that
and the chicks are on drugs she's doing
the press conference while she's on
drugs
what's his name brother the one the guy
that was in heat that de niro
put him in the rehab himself and then he
married heidi flights for a while
who was with heidi fleischmann um tom
yeah
that guy's been a junkie for 2000 years
all of a sudden
why can't i remember his last name size
more seismic all of a sudden
some girl comes up when she's 26
twitching
yeah he molested me on the movie set
when i was 11. that's great and dandy
dog
but you can't ruin somebody's life now
but do
what do you think is happening this is
my question like why are
why are people accepting these these
situations like the chris hardwick
situation or
why is everybody instantly thinking
that the guy's guilty no one giving him
a chicken
benefit of doubt no court no justice
court there's no nothing and in some
some cases like the worst case was
garrison keillor garrison keeler is the
host of the lake wobegon chronicles like
this
radio show on pbs i think it is is that
what it is
he apparently hugged a woman and his
hand went down her back
this is this is the the depiction and he
apologized to her
and he sent her an email she said don't
worry about it it's no big deal
it was nothing and then they continued i
believe to correspond and we're friends
again
and then this all the stuff started
happening with
al franken and then he had
this complaint brought up by this woman
she reintroduced
it and said that a long time ago he put
his hand on my back and they canceled
his show
they took his name off of it and
they did it like really quickly and it's
one of those things where you just go
okay really like the guy in
one moment in time touches someone's
back i don't know if it was creepy or
not
let's assume it was a terrible error and
it was creepy i don't think it was
i don't know i'm not saying i know
but that's it just touching someone's
back and you that is a hysterical
reaction that is hysteria it's almost
the definition of hysteria
you're not talking about an evil person
talking about a person who touched
someone's back like
we got to be real careful with what you
destroy a person's whole life with so on
the one side you have
the worst case scenario which is like a
bill cosby who's drugging people
and raping people it's the worst case
scenario for these
powerful elite type people that are
getting these women into their web and
particularly
he's another one which they were all in
on it and everybody knew about it for
years they knew about it was written
into his contract it was
sexual harassment clauses were in his
contract right
wasn't that it was known for years to
make sure we're correct
bothers me about harvey let me tell you
what bothers me about harvey what
we gotta indict everybody there's a lot
of people that have to be indicted and
this is one of those that's my feeling
my feeling right now that this would be
this should be a rico act
this is a rico act agents managers
oprah any because everybody knew
everybody but here's the question how
much do they know listen
everybody knew in 2005 right everybody
knew joe diaz was a coke fan
that's a different thing though man it's
the same let's pretend
the same thing okay but let's cook joe
diaz is a coke fiend it's 2007.
joe diaz comes to a party at your house
there's two cell phones missing
okay let me let me say this though do
you think that it's possible
that his behavior was shielded from some
of the people that he interacted with
like hillary clinton or oprah or bill
clinton or
who whoever it was that they some
high-profile people that he interacted
with is it possible they didn't know
is it possible they just thought he was
a [ __ ] hound no or do you think they
all know they knew he was a [ __ ] hound
and they heard a little chitter chatter
but
it's okay it's it's okay they would just
let him
that's number one that's crazy number
two jamie you ready for this
oh jesus okay i see joe uh whatever
not now but 25 years ago
i see joe when the first thing i had to
go is joe before you leave don't forget
i gotta tell you
what was that story gonna be about about
benson henderson's
choke about a joke that
somebody said at the store no about a
place i went to
and some chick took me in the back and
sucked my dick under the car and then
she stuck a finger in my ass and
that's what we talked about so if that's
what we talked about
you're gonna look me in the [ __ ] face
like a man that you are and the men that
you've been around
and told me harvey weinstein never
turned
to brad or his other bodies and the
setups
remind me to tell you a story about that
dirty [ __ ] album
for sure okay then for sure but that was
that's
that's been admitted i think they've had
conversations oh my god if you don't
think that
the wig ben affleck and the other guy
and i'm not offending nobody i'm just
talking about
boys we're boys right you and i have
boys what you won't say to jamie you'll
say to me because
you want you watch blind date no i'm
never watching it's a movie
blind date this movie firecrackers are
going off
there's a movie named blind date with
bruce willis oh
i remember that movie and kim bassinger
hilarious kim bassinger steals the show
when she walks in the japanese ladies
she's like you know you're entitled to
50 of your husband's assets in
california and the chinese woman kept
saying
me no speak english me don't you're
speak english 50 percent
and she opens at the door 50 50
that movie is a great movie but this is
seen in the opening of that movie
both of those actors are around where
the guy comes up to him he goes you're
not going to believe what happened last
night
and bruce willis goes here we go one of
these [ __ ]
sex stories again and he goes so i'm at
spagos i have for dinner
i walk out and some lady pulls up with a
limo and i say
i've never been a limo and she goes
we'll get in and we're riding down
sunset hard times in the summer
and next thing you know she's sucking my
dick she's got leotards on
i'm eating her ass and he's telling the
story and bruce willis listens and he
goes
no no why does this always happen to you
this is some other [ __ ] he goes and
he goes in his pocket he starts whipping
out polaroids
i've always known one of those guys in
my life
of course we've all known one guy in my
life but there's a difference between
that guy
and what harvey wants i don't believe
stuff yeah i know that
but i also believe that harvey weinstein
was telling people
he probably was because listen forever
what are you telling him was he telling
him that he was holding people down what
are they
usually telling him was he telling he
was raping people she was a piece of ass
no
not at all do you think that he did well
she's a piece of ass
she's a piece of ass she's got to see
her suck a dick right she'll do anything
she's an animal
that's what we do as men with
braggadocio so do you think that there
was like a community of that
where actors and actresses i think he
had
four or five guys that knew what he was
doing i want you to remember being 27
and having four year boys that would
come back every monday with a different
story to karate school
yeah i ate harass i [ __ ] her on fire
whatever the [ __ ] it is that you do he
told somebody somebody knew about all
these stories
some agents knew somebody because for
for the hundred of them that
said no and whatever they had to be 25
he was playing the percentages joe
well in fact a lot of people said yes
they blamed that one girl
they had that one girl that did rounders
they accused her yeah i heard that that
played matt damon's girlfriend
she was she went from being an extra and
[ __ ] uh
donnie brasco to being a guest star
opposite [ __ ] yeah if you watch
donnie brasco
she's what's his name sonny black's
girlfriend you know how many lines she
has in that movie
zero zero smart move
and then a year later she's uh a [ __ ]
guest yeah opposite
so yeah there's a bunch of them that
said yes do you but do you fault the
girl for doing that
like if a girl decides to talk harvey
weinstein
on her own free will john we come here
with a dream
and there's two ways to enhance that
dream there's either
i always knew that i wasn't good looking
i always knew i was fat and i always
knew i was r rated and
hard to listen to but i always knew that
i was funny so i always worked on being
funny
i didn't think somebody was gonna let me
suck that dick
or eat that [ __ ] to be a star so that
was all never in my mind but
think about people who how many people
have you met that would sell their soul
in this town how many people have come
and gone in front of you
the reason why our friendship is still
intact is because you know i'm a hard
worker you know harry's a hard worker
you respect hard work how many times
have you pulled me aside
and said look at this [ __ ] clown and
you're not trying to be judgmental you
just know that he's pulling the wool
over somebody's eyes
we know who's talking to talking we know
who's walking the walk we see it on
stage
we hear about it we don't need twitter
or facebook we hear about it
we get to that club the club owner will
tell you joey was here two weeks ago
he was falling asleep on stage you know
you're his [ __ ]
right so it's the same thing
do you agree yeah no i think so
i think um i think
what's one of the things that stand-up's
good for is that it's it's an exercise
you're doing while you're living your
life
and uh the better your standup gets it's
usually a better indication that you're
thinking better
like your your life's more in order
you're more tuned in
you know you're doing stuff that's
hitting harder because you've got better
points you know how to edit it better
and usually that that you can use that
i think it's like remember see remember
that movie mo betta blues
denzel washington i love that movie one
of things i loved about that movie
i got inspired to work on my act after
that movie i was like think about how
much musicians practice
he was just oh he's practicing and these
girls these hot girls would want to [ __ ]
and you're like no no right now i gotta
practice i gotta practice i was like
damn the discipline
crazy discipline that that man has to
play that trumpet and practice it over
and over again
and it made me really think like as a
comic we don't work like that we don't
have to rehearse all day
you know we don't really rehearse at all
but musicians like a really good
musician i mean they're always working
they're always trying and training and
working on their craft
and we do it on stage in front of people
probably more than
a lot of musicians do unless they're you
know constantly regularly touring
but it's we don't we don't have that
kind of a
work ethic attached to what we do like
if you want to play a phenomenal trumpet
those guys their breath control and the
way they can blow those horns man they
practice
all the time they put in hours and hours
working on that and i was thinking about
it like that's a different kind of craft
it's a different kind of craft the the
ability to play a musician
musical instrument the thing about stand
up that becomes a problem sometimes is
that it's kind of
you can kind of pull it off like you
could do it really
well or you can kind of pull it off and
to kind of pull it off you don't need a
whole lot of effort
you just need a few good subjects and a
few good ways of expressing it
but to get that where you can kind of
pull it off and turn it into a bit that
just smashes
a bit that you put in you can't wait to
get to that punch line because you know
it's going to be a nuclear bomb
that's where the real work comes in and
i think for a lot of us
it's the difference between how much
energy you put towards anything whether
it's your stand stand-up comedy or
painting or whatever the [ __ ] you do
how much energy you put towards your
writing how much energy you put towards
thinking about it
the more you can do the better it's
going to be and that's
a fundamental thing that nobody ever
tells you people tell you you should
write
but it's not just that you should write
you should also listen to your [ __ ] you
should also perform but the whole key to
it all
is just applying different kinds of
focus towards your act
and if you look at like a movie like mo
better blues like he's doing that
he's playing that [ __ ] trumpet and
you realize like this guy is like lost
in the act of practicing this beautiful
musical instrument
and this is his craft and he takes pride
in being excellent at his craft he could
just hang around all day and still
probably
blow an awesome tune at night but no he
[ __ ] practices
and i remember thinking about that going
damn that's probably something that's
missing from the lives of most stand-ups
and i should probably
try to think about that more with my own
life
i love i love the writing and i love the
performing
i hate the listening yeah that's a hard
part
this is very rough for me and i listened
i forced myself even before the special
i forced myself to listen a lot and it
made me too
[ __ ] over critical you know it got me
too over [ __ ] critical
a week before i taped i also went to
places that i didn't put my name on the
gazebo
just to see how my jokes would do in
front of regular people
and that [ __ ] with my head a little
bit i made a lot of couple little
mistakes in training camp
but that's what training camps are for
to learn you know
yes no i agree listen i've been doing
this for 27 years i love doing it i get
better every [ __ ] year
my breathing i get something better
going up on stage or confidence levels
and uh talk it's 27 [ __ ] years
you're gonna be doing a 30 this year
next month is going to be
[ __ ] years did you ever see yourself
doing this for 30 years i still remember
walking into the
main room and mitchie was in her booth
and paul was on stage slicing that room
apart
and she called me over and she goes
that's what happens when you've been
doing comedy for 20 years
at that time i was like damn i've been
doing comedy for 11.
i still got another nine
and now i'm at 27. crazy
and it's like you watch people like john
jack right
who will [ __ ] you up effortlessly
like mm-hmm without even breathing heavy
john jacob
yeah you'll be in you'll get that
[ __ ] hillary you think you got him in
the [ __ ] guillotine
yeah next thing you know you're on your
back looking up with your arm in the
[ __ ]
and that's what kind of we're doing
right now i feel myself
when i see a guy with a coral belt on
i'm like that's the level now that we're
at i can control
a lot of [ __ ] joe one of your secrets
was following me was putting yourself in
bad positions
yeah which in jiu jitsu is like getting
the biggest guy in the room and going
hey
are you busy right now dude i tell
people that i was taking you on the road
with me they'd be like what the [ __ ]
getting wrong
get on top of me and just choke me you
taking me on the road
is like somebody going hey come here for
a second
what do you weigh 300 i weigh 140. get
on top of me
in a mouth and put one hand in and we'll
start there
yeah let's start right there let's start
right [ __ ] there but all
only if you think about it that way see
this is what's what was important about
it and there's one one of the things
that's important about traveling with
all really funny people
it only becomes a negative when you
think at it as a negative
when someone's funny you should be
laughing and enjoying it
and it makes your time more enjoyable
when you go on stage yes it does
i needed to learn that and the way i
learned that one of the ways was going
on the road with you
i knew that you were going to crush and
so i knew
that everybody else would like to take
you know we were both
relatively young in our comedy careers
back then right so it was like we're
talking about
i've been doing comedy maybe nine years
or eight years but you were a lot
wiser about the game like you introduced
me to [ __ ] that i had never even like i
read a few books
and watched a few tapes but you had the
practical knowledge that i needed like
you were the vote tech school
well what i did is i i thought about the
same way i thought about martial arts
that's one of the reasons why i wanted
to go on the road with you all the time
i was like you don't get better at
sparring people that suck
you get better when you spar with
wizards you've got to be real careful
when you're sparring with wizards
and so it's like what i would need to do
is have someone who goes on stage in
front of me and just crushes
and we had some i had some tough sets
going on after you remember one time in
rascals
rascals and uh west orange right it was
in west orange or east orange
west west orange new jersey [ __ ]
great club
but you went up and you got into it with
some people in the audience about
something and you were just on
fire just on fire
you crushed and i had a real hard time
going on after you
and i remember thinking oh okay this is
a very important lesson like this is
important like there's something that
i'm not doing right that he is doing
right
like what am i uh how come i'm not oh
i'm nervous i'm nervous going on after
him so i'm not having fun up there
so he's having fun and i'm being tense
going oh jesus better not suck
so i'm putting in my head this better
not suck it's the total wrong way to
approach
if you approached a fight like that man
you're going to get smashed
most likely you want to approach a fight
thinking about the things you're going
to do
not the things that you want to like
worry about what's going to happen if
you get hit you don't think like that
you just think about doing your thing
and then adjusting along the way
and i had the wrong mindset and i needed
to see someone kill a bunch of times in
front of me and then bomb go after them
to realize okay something's wrong here
the wrong thing is i'm going on stage
tense because someone was funny that's
ridiculous like i should be the opposite
i should be happy that someone was funny
because i love comedy
and this is what i like to do i mean i
like to watch it if i'm not doing it so
why am i so tense
it's just a bad way of approaching a
problem
and i think this is one of the things
that [ __ ] people up in life
you approach a problem the same way
every time and you never
stop and just completely look at the
whole thing from the top down just look
at the whole thing go what
what am i trying to do here i'm trying
to get tighter and funnier and better
what do i got to do i got to do a lot of
sets
i got to write and i got to work with
murderers that was the key
it's like working with guys like you and
all of us working together and also
people knew if they came to see us
like hey this isn't just going to be joe
goes up and he's the hero of the show no
you're going to get ari who's going to
go on in murder you're going to go on in
murder and then i'm going to go up
i mean it's a [ __ ] rock'em sock'em
robots show we had
we went on the road dude we did college
i mean um clubs rather across the
country
we did i mean who knows how many [ __ ]
cities you and i and ari toured on
[ __ ] crazy numbers just over and over
again bonding together
hundreds of shows together figuring out
how to [ __ ] get everything perfect
figure out the
right amount of weed to smoke before you
go on stage the right amount of getting
joey diaz riled up
you would come in yelling about
something or here oh i want you to see
something i'd go into the bathroom
there'd be a [ __ ] that looks like a
crocodile trying to crawl out of the
toilet bowl
all that stuff that that's some rock and
roll comedy man
you know it helped both of us it helped
both of us a lot
and it also like set a tone that i think
for a lot of us like you should
be with funny people should all
everybody should try hard
should not like think that anybody doing
good is bad for you it's great it's
great for you it's great for everybody
that everybody's like doing good
together is better for everybody
when i go on the road now i go under the
road under those joe rogan principles
like that's my whole road thing the only
thing i added to the only geekundo i
added to it is my travel
i'm in and out fast i don't [ __ ] around
i can't rent the car i don't want to see
nobody
i'm in and out yeah let's go right over
there you know there's no radio
necessary i play
just like you now we don't know yeah
they'll try
yeah because they have relationships
with local radio stations they're like
you know kcwi wants to get you in there
i go in because you want to talk to the
people yeah on the way up
the same people push your way down
there's a lot of people that were there
for me when i wasn't so i just do that
station
the problem is that waking up in the
morning yeah yeah when you get probably
just killing
it and you gotta get in there a day
earlier
because if you wanna do friday morning
you gotta get in there thursday now you
can't just show up friday three o'clock
in the afternoon
i can't do it i fly out thursday at
[ __ ] six am that's the best you got
out of me
right because i got the family and i got
yeah we got a lot of [ __ ]
it's not like it used to be men so but
the thing that i love
about like this time is that even though
people are super sensitive like we were
talking about people are like real
sensitive about like getting in trouble
for stuff
there's still rock'em sock talking
robots comedy going on
it's still wild out there like dudes are
still doing
crazy [ __ ] jokes it's it's fun
people are taking real chances they're
doing real stand-up
you know and it's there's a lot of them
there's bill burr there's you
i mean you can go down the list ari are
you doing some real stand up
you know there's a bunch of real killers
now santino
he's doing some dangerous stand up you
know [ __ ] i'm right now
i'm writing from my that's it like the
reason the point of that [ __ ] story i
told you
of being on top of that hill at 17 and
being homeless
is because i had a lot of chances to ice
myself joe
and a lot of chances to ice myself think
of getting out of [ __ ] prison
and thinking of getting out on bail when
i got out on bail i had a lot of [ __ ]
doubts my friend
then getting out of bail and knowing
you're gonna look at 48 [ __ ] years
and you're a [ __ ] loser as it is
think of all those opportunities i used
to break into a friend's house to sleep
in this house at night
i slept in a rocket ship for a month
outside of the park you go to a park and
see those rocket ships and your kids
play on them
i still remember going up to the third
floor of the rocket ship finishing off
my coke and jerking off
on the third floor at five in the
morning outside
in a [ __ ] park with leaves around me
and [ __ ]
there was a lot of times i had
that one the visual is amazing you have
no [ __ ] idea i would go up to the
third floor
with a bottle of [ __ ] smirnoff silver
vodka
a bag a hooded sweatshirt gloves with a
missing finger
so i could [ __ ] touch the rock and
put them in my nose and [ __ ]
you know what no no no no that's all
funny that's all funny on the way up the
stairs and [ __ ] but when you're
when you come down and you're in that
rocket ship and it's five in the morning
and it's 20 [ __ ] two below
zero oh and you're you're thinking to
yourself [ __ ] god took away my mother
god did this this is all god's fault
because this the same god that i
was raised to believe that was going to
help me is doing all this
a lot of times i wanted to [ __ ] do a
swan dive
but i didn't you know it's so [ __ ]
weird i was in those positions for a
long time joe
yeah now i gotta look at you and go
jesus christ look at like turn is no no
tina turner's son killed himself
yesterday
it wasn't like son though i thought it
was like son with it
you know this trend of [ __ ] people
icing themselves that scares me that
concerns me
is this something we're eating is it
something that we're getting weak on
you know there was no drugs in the
ordained system so we can't blame
[ __ ] prescription
drugs you know he was on one medication
some sort of medication
um and it was something that was
prescribed for him someone told me that
it was malaria medication i don't know
probably i don't know if they've
released that but i'm sure he had to
take some of that stuff sometimes but
you know you don't know what it was that
did him in i mean according to some
people he
really wasn't doing well you know i
don't i don't know i need to
i mean it's almost
unnecessary to get for me to get the
full story i miss the guy he's gone
that's it you know i mean i don't need
to
i think when whenever someone does
something like that whatever it is if
there's one thing that people could
point to
and say hey there's a chemical that's
responsible for this or there's a
a gene problem that's responsible for
this or like how could someone who's
loved so much
want to step out i mean that must be a
terrible moment of pain i didn't want to
do it
i had done you ever been on the computer
listening to music on youtube
and you're writing right and it just
keeps playing songs and you know you
don't have no control of it i think i
i started with leonard skinner the
simple man
i kept going on the let's get a trip and
i went and i came back
and at one point blow up the outside
world oh and i'm sitting there
and he says that line about going out or
something
joe broken my lip started shaking like
i'm like
i don't even know this guy and i miss
him i don't know this guy
you want me to look you people and tell
you i know i met creole i met chris
i don't know i don't know i nev i saw
him one time at the comedy store
six feet away from me chris cornell
that's it
and i started crying like how could
somebody like this go in a room
and just ice themselves is this what i'm
gonna do because i'm in this [ __ ]
entertainment field because
what what happens and then i think about
all these times
one time i broke into my friend's house
and i broke in the window and it was
freezing so i couldn't even sleep in
that room i had to sleep in the hallway
and there was a mattress on the wall
that had like pistons from all the kids
and i pulled it down i slept on it and
when i woke up he had a dog and
when it was it was too cold he just let
the dog [ __ ] downstairs
and there was like 20 pieces of little
rolled up [ __ ] that had been
you know like when the the juice goes
out of them they just roll up
what's those things that you use as a
organ what are those
accordions accordions it was like a
piece of [ __ ] shrinks like an accordion
when the moisture goes out of it it
really does so if you take a [ __ ] that's
this big
right and you put it in a box come back
a week later it's like this
big how do i know that because i did it
to a guy in prison i took a [ __ ] in a
welfare box one time you know
oh jesus you know the boxes of cheese
where the cheese comes in american
cheese yes this dude had long hair and
would always try to play me like he
was with the biker dudes oh [ __ ] in the
box for him but he played he where he
lived in the key
worked in the kitchen he forgot i ran
the kitchen and it was all me and black
dudes
so one day i got one of the welfare
cheese boxes
and i took like a 22 24 inch
it looked like a lizard it just it was
just a long
like you know thin at the end like one
of those things that tapered like a
snail that's what it looked like a long
brown snail
and i fit it perfectly into this cheese
box and i took a flag on the american
flag like
from the cheese and i put it on top and
i put it in this drawer
and every night and he had the first
bunk
on the way out so everybody had to walk
back and all the black guys would open
the door and go
god damn it smells like [ __ ] in this
[ __ ] and he kept saying i know
it does
i don't know why it smells like [ __ ] in
here and after like a month when they
went in this drawer
everybody kept saying man it smells like
[ __ ] in here he went in this drawer
opened it up and he found this box
he opened it up and i never forget him
knocking on my bunk going
i'm gonna find out who did this to me
like what they do to you
and he goes look at this like what is it
and i knew it was [ __ ]
but it had shrunken down from the 24
inches
to like six little inches it just shrunk
down when all the moisture goes out
it just shrunk down like a [ __ ] um
i don't even know why i'm telling you
that story that's a hilarious story
that's [ __ ] crazy
it's a hilarious story these are fun
times joey diaz i think we're the last
of the regular humans
i think we got our children's generation
maybe one more after that
and i really do believe it's over i
think we're going to integrate with
[ __ ] computers i think we're real
close to it now can't even go whole
podcast without looking on our phone oh
what's the time is it
you know it's weird we're going to
integrate with computers
we're going to all be living in some
weird world we got this [ __ ] virtual
reality thing here now
the htc vibe you should try this thing
out
freaky the [ __ ] out you think you're in
another place
there's zombie games and games where
you're you're on top of a castle
defending the castle shooting arrows
down
at monsters that are coming at you
we're we're entering into a weird world
right now joey diaz
computers that's not that we've got too
much information
it's a part of these things too much
listen on this thing i do not have
social media good for you you do know
that i only have twitter on here
oh that's social media i don't have
facebook i don't have nothing else but
that is social media yeah my bit
my hotmail hotmail oh
nobody even people when i tell people
how male they go what the [ __ ] are you
talking about so you limit your int your
interaction that's good that's smart
limit my interaction on the road the
ipad
no social media i'm convinced netflix
and a writing app on my ipod
that's it what do you use for writing
app uh whatever app came with it
writing whatever and it has sections so
i have jokes books
i have chapters this that thoughts
things i'm working on
is it notes is that what you write on i
don't know what it's called like
it looks like yellow paper no no no no
no no notes
i have on the phone right and i write on
here from time to time but nothing too
far but you write
on something that's on a ipad yeah so
what i do is
i'll write on a notebook in the mornings
and then once i take the baby to
whatever i'll go to the coffee shop and
transfer it if i really like it
to the ipad and i'll work on it from
there and then i look at the whole thing
as a whole now instead of in a notebook
and i don't know my spelling and i can't
remember what that word was
the social media part is the big part of
all this that i'm talking about is that
we're just getting closer and closer to
each other in some weird ways this is
going to be
nothing compared to the next wave
whatever the next wave is but they
really do figure out a way to integrate
either virtual reality or what they're
calling augmented reality like you'll
wear
a pair of sunglasses and you can have
google maps sitting up on it you can
google things you can see
images give you navigation it's gonna
get real weird joey see joe rogan i'm
still a fan of life
me too and it bothers people and it
bothers me
when somebody's not a fan of life so i
don't want them around me anymore who's
not a fan of life
a lot of people we forgot really we've
forgotten yeah yeah too many cameras
yeah too many pictures too many videos
listen i was raised in society
you don't see too many really tough to
me to find pictures of me
as a young kid really tough
yeah there's not a lot of pictures taken
back a society where no when i came from
a society would put the camera away
right good what's that for uh it's a
part with the camera
yeah why but put the camera away well we
need more of that backstage right we
need more of that in life
in my way you know we live you know i'm
a stern believer i don't like text
messages
not because i'm a prick or a douche bag
i want to hear joe rogan's voice
no we've talked about some people i
don't want to hear your [ __ ] voice
i want to hear your voice because i know
what you're thinking if i hear your
voice
you can't i care about you i care about
you too so i want to hear your voice
i always tell you people that i love
that thing that you do like you don't
want to have
you're like my one friend the only time
i ever text you is if you text me first
yeah i'll text you back but i call you
we talk on the phone you have to check
in you have to have that you
you have to be as human these days i
don't have nothing on my books
you know i don't want to do comedy but
guess what i'll do i'll push myself i'll
be sore
and i'll push myself to go roll because
that's human contact
and it's it's it's it's the most
positive human contact
you'll ever have right think about it
yeah i mean you roll on the street we're
fighting about something
but me and you hit knuckles and i grab
your ghee and i pull you into my no
it's fun and [ __ ] that's his human
kind
so i know i'm not gonna do this and i'm
not gonna do that tonight i'm gonna
write a little bit maybe spend some time
with the girls
maybe i'm gonna take the girls for
dinner but i also know that i'm gonna
make myself have that human contact of
jiu-jitsu
oh you're gay joey you're just a closet
[ __ ] cause you're rolling with men
that's great but i had human contact i
had an emotion
i shook hands with a guy a guy sweat on
me and i sweat on a man
yeah which builds a certain type of
emotion between two men
and then they'll have to be homosexual
that's a different type of [ __ ] man
it really is
it is when you stop what you're doing
and go joey joey
stop and while you're teaching me
something
i'm sweating on my fat [ __ ] potato
chip sweat
is sweating on joe rogan's neck but
you're going joey
grab my neck ah squeeze
ah yeah there you go now do that to me
next time
you know what that does to your psyche
as a man
that a man that's beating you is
teaching you
how to let get up so joe i got you in
this guillotine but stick your hand
there
going you're sweating and you're like i
can't
i'm tired no no no no just put your hand
in there one time just squeeze real
tight
oh there you go joey joey you're [ __ ]
killing me jesus that's
a complete different part of a man i
think so too
i think that that's your boy i think
it's good for you
the human contact it also it alleviates
the tension
of like men have tension that they might
get into a physical altercation
you don't think that way if you do
justice it's great you relax walking
people are scared of vitamin d this
society has scared people of the
sunlight
you got to get out in the sun a little
bit that kills depression
there's depression people talk about
again you know many times i have to be
depressed you know how many times i've
had
opportunities to call you up and go i'm
depressed
i get depressed for 10 [ __ ] minutes
right then i smoked this
roots and expired [ __ ] and i think of
something that you said and i laughed my
[ __ ] ass off
you know on the way up here i was hiding
[ __ ] and i used to be this guy that used
to [ __ ] with me at a body shop
as a detailer used to [ __ ] with me every
day
couldn't beat him up he's a lot bigger
than i would so i had to use my mind so
i saw a dead mouse one day
and i took it i put in his jacket pocket
and he was driving to work one morning
and he went in his pocket for a
cigarette and he found the mouse and he
crashed his car
oh joey we're at almost like
four hours all right let's get the [ __ ]
out of here
let's get the [ __ ] out of here i love
you thank you very much for having me
uh vegas is sold out utah's sold out
i'm in kansas city with you i'm at the
improv while you're in
doing the theater like gentlemen and
then i'm
in uh nashville and huntsville alabama
at the end of the year but besides that
i'm home
so pleasure seeing you look great i love
you brother we'll take your offer up and
we'll train and we'll have jamie
yeah man we'll just do that we'll come
in we'll do a cycle of
uh the different um cardiovascular
machines
and then we'll do a circuit of the
cardiovascular machines and do a circuit
of like some kettlebell exercises
would do can you do chin ups do you do
chain ups at all how's your shoulder
look terrible terrible okay have you
ever done clubs you've done clubs yes
aubry sent me clubs i do have a little
crane club workout
friday i'm going to see my man joe
schilling and [ __ ] beautiful
a little tune up from uncle joe
beautiful beautiful
we got a bunch of [ __ ] out here we got
medicine balls and yeah i see him i see
him you'll have a nice workout okay man
we can do that what time do you usually
get here i know you drop the girls off
and then you shoot right over right a
lot of times i come here early and work
out but sometimes i can't do it until
the afternoon but we'll work something
out we'll do some [ __ ]
and thank you for the experience of
disneyland jesus [ __ ] christ bro
it's fun right but just the way you told
me to do it like i looked at it my
wife's like what are you crazy i go
listen
the man says there's only one way to do
it i invited our brother eddie we had a
great time with the kids
yeah i heard it was awesome i heard it
was awesome [ __ ] thank you brother
thank god for some
place like disneyland when you have kids
when you when you didn't have kids
you're like
gives a [ __ ] about disneyland but when
you have kids it's like oh
did i tell you they stopped me at the
gate because they found the metabolism
yeah you did tell me
they [ __ ] you had to go
happy fourth of july bye
[Applause]
[Music]